the united states is canceling a routine
intercontinental ballistic missile test
because they're actually concerned about
escalation of nuclear war i think this
shows the us is taking it seriously and
i think it's good news i think it shows
that there is an interest in preventing
it right now we're hearing that russia
is well their foreign minister has said
world war three will be nuclear it will
be devastating effectively telling nato
if you interfere in ukraine with what's
going on you're going to start world war
iii it's going to be nuclear and i think
the one thing we should all be focusing
on is whatever we can to make sure
something like that doesn't happen
i don't believe in mutually assured
destruction though and and we'll get
into that i do think a nuclear war would
be devastating but i don't think it
would be like the movies so i will just
stress it it is good news is happening
we have a bunch of really crazy news
though coming out of what's happening
with ukraine ea sports is going to be
removing russian teams from video games
the iron man is banning russian and
belarusian athletes these are civilians
they're talking about shutting there was
a call i guess uh someone in ukraine
wants russia to be cut off from the
internet you know everybody needs to
calm down a little bit
certainly i think russia's invasion is
wrong they're the aggressors
but let's try and de-escalate things
that's why i wanted to leave with a
story about the us canceling this
minuteman 3 icbm test because i think
it's i think it's a it's a good gesture
so far
it's just a test i don't think it's it
means a whole lot but you know i want to
have some good news i don't want to just
be like the apocalypse the world is
ending so we're going to talk about this
and then we got something that i think
is absolutely fascinating chile has
passed an anti-discrimination bill
for for employment where you cannot
discriminate against someone who has
altered their genetic material or have
been mutated
now that is strange and i think it'll be
interesting to talk about especially in
the context of the great reset the world
economic forum and uh just a lot of
what's been going on with these strange
international dealings joining us to
discuss all of this is magic noise hey
it's magit imagine
so who are you what are you doing good
to be here
um
i'm here to have great conversation with
all you guys i am
based in the uk for your viewers and
listeners i
uh have a uh up until recently used to
have a show in the uk on the largest
commercial radio group um that ended
in some controversy and i'll be setting
up soon my own show uh to stand on my
own feet and hopefully broadcast again
from the uk we've just acquired a studio
actually looking forward to it you
should come on my show when we're ready
yeah yeah yeah absolutely you were on
lbc right i was yeah what london
broadcasting is leading britain's
conversation oh i'm way off yeah
it started no you're right it started as
london's
i think it was london's biggest
conversation back in the old days but
then it very soon went national and that
and then obviously via online broadcast
went global
um and uh it was uh we had a i had a
weekend show it was doing quite well but
my views on um opposing mandates covered
mandates i call them and uh calling out
klaus schwab yeah yeah they led they led
to some difficulties and controversy
that'll be interesting to talk about so
we'll definitely get into that i think
that uh absolutely has a a role to play
in um it plays a role in in the conflict
you were mentioning something that we'll
get into that this journalist who is
saying world war three has started and
calling on boris johnson to to start you
know trigger a no-fly zone you said that
she was a young global leader for the
world economic forum yeah i mean do you
want me to we can pull that up actually
we'll pull it up
just as a preview i'll mention that so
we'll get into all that stuff and uh
that was in poland yes and yet warsaw it
was crazy crazy story i didn't know that
you brought it up yeah so this is going
to be fascinating conversation and uh so
thanks for coming we also have
love doctor is that what you want to
love doctor coughlin as they call me
hosting like shim cats
he
we talked about this before i'm love
doctor coughlin people ask advice from
me you were going to give me a show on
your network oh yeah that's right i
support it tim has a very selective
memory here yeah sure but uh i am seamus
coughlin love dr coughlin host of shim
cast creator of freedom tunes uh i'm
wearing a suit because it is ash
wednesday and i was at mass and as you
know when i wear a suit i take over the
show so this is this is shim cast
i'm very glad you guys shameless imagine
you guys majid it's a major imagination
both work oh one is uh the majid is the
urdu pronunciation and majid is the
arabic was the first word
is the what pronunciation
yeah which is the language in pakistan
and hindi and india is the same language
but different script do you have a
preference uh majid works it because
that's yeah in the uk that's pretty much
from school age where people okay i'm
glad you're here you know i'm it's ash
wednesday like you said and i'm big on
like bringing islam and christianity
together and maybe we'll do that today
sure or at least work towards it we're
gonna fix that man
you think we're going to convert all of
them to christianity one step at a time
baby yeah the journey is the destination
it's like 50 years or later and there's
like some kids in school and they're
like well the unification happened when
sheamus
had a conversation right all truth has
had truths have been revealed
we got ladies
yes i am also here very excited for our
i think this is our first guest from the
uk hopefully we're going to be doing
more but i've been on before with the
tim that's right paul but that was a
different thing that was before this
show right yeah yeah yeah so i still
what happened to that show
so that's i still do it um i just don't
do interviews how many shows do you have
man well i have three youtube channels
yeah and um
so
two of them are very similar it's like
me monologuing yeah but the uh the the
tim
youtube.comcast is
talking at the biggest story of the day
or whatever and then the
youtube.com teamcastnews is kind of like
morning news and then some culture
things what did i come with you on the
tim pool my original youtube channel
right so i interviewed you on there og
and basically what happens is i decided
to move interviews to a different format
yeah instead because it was like it
didn't work if people like listening to
just like me straight talking about news
yeah very different from a conversation
so we kind of split them off yeah but uh
yeah yeah i interviewed you out and i'm
pretty sure it was california i can't
remember i remember meeting you we were
in a room somewhere you had a little
thing
i think it was london man i think so but
they're all a little bit nice man it was
a while back though it was a few years
ago is it still online
oh yeah yeah we'll probably find it
right yeah you were talking about the
regressive left yeah that was early days
man before that yeah before that phrase
became popularized somebody was like you
gotta talk to magic he coined the term
regressive left yeah you know what it
was before so i had this chat with sam
harris in this um eventually became this
book
that he and i co-authored together islam
and the future of tolerance
and i used it in in that conversation
with him and the and the phrase blew up
but actually it had already been used in
my autobiography radical which i think
is 2012.
i was very upset with the left because
they they had adopted this kind of
relative approach to morality that i i
found was uh seeds of tyranny yeah
precisely well we'll get into that too
so uh before we get started head over to
timcast.com become a member help support
our work we're gonna have an absolutely
fascinating
members only segment so if you go to
timcast.com you will get access to
segments from the tim cast irl podcast
which go up around 11 p.m monday through
thursday we didn't have one yesterday
because it was a state of the union and
you know lauren got drunk and it was
great you know we we
yeah what was that
yeah yeah
we were we were drinking every time
biden did something you know like
predictable she was just drinking old
times she was just drinking the whole
time
but it was funny when biden said we got
to secure secure our borders he just
yells based
laughing like i can't believe biden
would say that it was it was fun but uh
we went we went long and we didn't have
a member segment we're gonna have one
tonight it's gonna be really fascinating
so you're not uh don't miss it as a
member you're helping keep all of our
journalists employed and you're helping
us expand the website and things have
been going pretty well thanks to all of
you who are supporting our work so don't
forget to also smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
wherever you can take the url post it on
facebook twitter whatever you can do if
you want to help out spread the word and
then let's get into this first story
which i think is it's it's small but i
think we got some good news here the
wall street journal reports u.s cancels
icbm test
a test launch amid ukraine tensions the
move follows putin's threat to increase
readiness of russia's nuclear forces
they say the bite administration has
cancelled a routine test launch of an
air force minuteman iii missile to avoid
escalating nuclear tensions with russia
u.s officials said wednesday the air
force had planned to conduct the test
launch from vandenberg air force base in
the early hours of thursday march 3rd
and wednesday however the administration
decided to postpone the test launch amid
tensions with kremlin over ukraine so
the news that was coming out is that the
foreign minister in in russia said
world war three will be nuclear it will
be devastating basically
some have called it a thin thinly veiled
threat to nato you screw with us we drop
bombs
others have said it's kind of just a
truth
that it will come to nuclear war and
then he's not trying to say you know
we'll we'll blow you up but uh i i see
this as maybe not the most important or
impactful thing in the world but i think
it shows the us is not willing to push
to push to to bring us to that conflict
if even for just something as small as a
routine test right so but what do you
what do you think do you think there's a
real prospect for uh escalation outside
of ukraine well there is there is a
danger of escalation
if you look to
what some of the politicians are
are pushing there you you look at some
of the voices and how they've been
talking about this war
and it's worrying i don't think it's
going to happen
but i do worry about some of these
voices it's interesting if you notice a
pattern right the same voices that
wanted to
uh to impose coveted mandates on
everybody else to protect themselves are
the same voices that would want to send
our sons and relatives to war to protect
themselves
yep well i'll tell you i got i got some
applications for the army for everybody
who's in favor of u.s intervention by
all means sign on up and head on over
and they won't [ __ ] of course they'd
rather we go they don't want to go
they'd rather we go and and and serve
their aims and their purposes we're
still i think they'd rather your
children go yeah exactly horrifying yeah
and that's how it's always been though
you know everyone you're still fighting
age though
me uh i'm 35 i'm gonna be 36 and seven
days he's still fighting age i suppose
don't say he's gonna start walking
around with a cane okay and i will i
will i will brag my resting heart rate
48. don't say you're all right well you
just got drafted buddy good job my
goodness i'm i i've been uh i got this
health app and i've been you know blood
pressure has improved dramatically
making it worse i've been exercising
you're a super soldier is what you're
saying i'm just like i don't want to
fight in the war but i would be the best
soldier i'd win it by myself this is i'm
just it's like i feel like it's a great
accomplishment for myself to be getting
healthy you know i feel like everybody
should do that absolutely they're going
to brag about it
well if the military's watching i'm just
in horrible shape there's no sheamus
sheamus feet are so flat
ever yeah exactly i mean i can say
that's good news i'm happy they're doing
this uh because it is it's good to
de-escalate but some of the rhetoric i
mean we had the mayor of london
talk about look you know if there is a
nuclear attack on london we're ready
that kind of rhetoric is just
unnecessary i think considering what's
going on and what's going on is worrying
i mean look putin invaded a country
right nobody can countenance or can or
condone in the invasion of any country i
just find it strange that the voices
that
some of the voices that till this day
don't accept it was wrong to invade iraq
or afghanistan right are now condemning
putin's invasion of a foreign country i
seem to think of it as we're invading
iraq right now it's a constant invasion
we're still there yeah it is occupation
we are occupying and invading that
country on a daily basis by being there
it's not like it happened and it
happened in the past it's happening
right now the thing is what i find
amazing with this and i i think it's
it's really interesting that we're i
believe we're in george orwell in 1984
split the world up
into uh four different um
uh
blocks right oceana which was landing
strip one which is the uk and then
america and its
sphere of influence which includes what
we call the five eyes so australia
canada new zealand the anglo-saxon
sphere the other block that orwell used
in in 1984 was east asia and that just
considered china in that area and then
he had eurasia right eurasia was russia
and europe
and then there was the disputed
territory which if you think about today
it's very accurate it was the muslim
majority lands
that are the subject of the whims of the
other three and and still disputed right
so if you look at how orwell divided the
world it's so curious to me today that
when you look at these blocks emerging
and you look at the current conflict you
can see a eurasia the russian sphere of
influence emerging you can see
post-brexit oceana emerging which is the
anglo-saxon world and you can see china
already there with east asia and you can
see that they are all fighting over the
resources in the middle east it's very
curious to see how accurate orwell's
vision of the world was i wonder if it's
a self-fulfilling prophecy like jules
verne would draw the submarine eight in
1820 or whatever well before they ever
created them and then you know art
becomes a reality submarines prior to
that actually yeah yeah very primitive
ones in fact there were plans for
submarines drawn up as early as like the
late 1500s
yeah davinci for instance would would
pen like um helicopters he would draw
those well before they were ever i
wonder if orwell created a fantasy realm
that is now being created yeah he got
the date wrong
yeah 1984 we're in 2022. however i do
think it was more than um a coincidence
like the man he saw that coming the man
served in wars abroad he kind of had a
quite a strong grip on on world affairs
but he was a man looking through a
keyhole trying to see the entirety of a
ballroom yeah and so if you look at
brave new world i think we're seeing
elements of that absolutely fahrenheit
451 yeah prophetic and a v for vendetta
even i mean there's like
yeah uh or graphically and graphic novel
yeah that's right yeah so uh graphic
novel is very very different i've not
read it but it was very different but
the where i was going with this though
is that we are unaware of how we are
perceived in oceania i'm going to use
that phrase to refer to the anglo-saxon
world today just to continue with
orwell's um kind of you know point there
we're unaware how we're perceived so
when we condem and we should condemn
russia's invasion of ukraine what we
don't realize is that the vast majority
of the rest of the world the vast
majority of humanity
are laughing at us because we're still
in iraq this you brought up earlier how
valuable it is to know what the world is
like before the internet if you know
what the world is like before the
invasion of iraq you know that it's not
normal and it's the bastardization of
truth and justice and honesty and
leadership and we've completely lost any
moral high ground to talk about this and
that's part of the problem that you know
the the media is whipping up such a
frenzy over this and then i remember
just two years ago i went on a five-day
hunger strike because of the uyghur
genocide in china i remember that and
the purpose was to get a hundred
thousand signatures on a a petition
because there's a parliamentary petition
if you get a hundred thousand signatures
on that petition you force a debate in
parliament now we got that um a hundred
thousand within five days
and then it went to parliament and then
they voted unanimously
on the fact that there was a genocide in
china but it was only a symbolic vote
which is why it got through it would not
have got through if it wasn't a symbolic
vote so you've got these talking heads
like the mayor of london and others like
certain politicians war hawks who were
talking about
the need to impose a no-fly zone
over ukraine which would mean that we
shoot down russian jets which is an act
of war right so these idiots don't
realize that you end up declaring war in
russia if you do that those same voices
were not only quiet about the genocide
in china the uyghur genocide but
resisted any effort to hold china
accountable for it yeah exactly well we
had the olympics there and we still sent
our athletes over and what were you
mentioning earlier tim with the the
russians that we were
pulling their athletes or can you
refresh me yeah so well uh several
organizations have banned russian and
belarusian athletes from competing like
iron man did it yeah and uh there's a
there's a couple others triathlons the
spirit of the olympics is that even if
you're at war you send your best
athletes you let them pass through your
territory unhindered and then they all
compete because it's the spirit of human
competition it's beyond warfare i just
find it so out of touch and then there
there are these calls look again i'm
gonna have to reemphasize every time i
say something on this topic but again
putin should not have gone into ukraine
but he's not hitler and there are these
people saying he's the new hitler when
you've got an active genocide going on
in china and the worst part of this is
when you talk about hitler and nazism in
ukraine in 2014 there was a change of
regime that we in the west encouraged
the maidan uprising that putin would
call a coup now whatever word you want
to use there was regime change that we
we meaning our intelligence agencies
backed with full throttle wholeheartedly
we backed that regime change because the
government in ukraine was pro-russia it
pulled out of the affiliation with the
eu and we didn't like that we wanted it
to be pro-west so we backed that regime
changing who we bring to power nazis
actual nazis
do you think zolensky or no no he's not
a nazi he's jewish but the you've got
this thing called the azov brigade yeah
yeah the battalion right
as of battalion they are an armed nazi
but now the word nazi the problem is
it's been so overused today that nobody
really believes the word nazi or racist
when it actually deserves to be used but
let's just be very clear these guys have
uh they are swastika raising actual
neo-nazis and i mean that in the literal
sense of the word and even the word
literal is no longer literally yeah
that's true we gotta bring the word
figure it's literally been changed it
means something else we talked about
this with lauren southern as well it is
unbelievable right and they are they are
formally incorporated
into the ukrainian national guard we
funded them by the way we when i say we
funded them actually sent them money
uh we trained them we funded them uh
canada the us and the uk were involved
in backing this uh battalion and then
they were incorporated into the
ukrainian national guard and then once
uh putin attacked
the ukrainian national guard from their
official and formal and verified twitter
account posted a video
bragging that this was an azov fighter
dipping bullets in pig's lard saying
that he was gonna go and find the
muslims it's like that uh that that
urban legend that apocrypha story are
you familiar
there's always
there's a an american general in in the
middle east you know uh killed a bunch
of islam soldiers yeah and then but kept
one alive
and put pig's blood on the corpses and
said go tell everyone what we did but
it's not i believe that story's not true
yeah i i don't think but this is of this
one is a video
right and the thing is i'm saying it's
probably he probably saw that meme story
on the internet and maybe but the thing
is put let's let's put aside the
emotional um reaction that some people
may have to that video right and
consider it strategically
the mistake historically that
chamberlain made was to appease nazism
in europe in the belief that they could
be of use to defeat the soviet union
so we know how that ended what you've
got at the moment is you've got a nazi
battalion as formally incorporated into
the ukrainian army in their military
and neo-nazis from around the world are
now traveling there to train with them
they are armed and they are part of the
ukrainian armed forces my question is if
if they win or if ukraine is split to
east and west and they've got the river
in the middle if putin takes from the
upper river putin takes eastern ukraine
and the ukrainian regime that's there
currently keeps the western part the
nazis that are serving in their national
guard in their army who are pretty much
the most powerful faction in terms of
grassroots mobilization i mean guys
there are videos of children's summer
camps in ukraine making nazi salutes
there's nazi summer camps they've had
mass rallies these are actual proper
organized nazis with swastikas with
insignia and everything now
imagine in whichever part they end up
maintaining they are now the government
so you've got an actual nazi government
that we sounded sounds a lot like isis
yeah sounds like an easy target why how
did al qaeda get created well the cia
were funding what they the mujahideen
that's right right to defeat the soviets
now in if it's not okay to they don't
learn do that no it's something over and
over again it's intentional they did
learn and they here's the thing they do
study history it's just that world war
ii is the only thing that ever happened
in all of history so anytime anything
happens we we have to say that guy is
hitler and so like you said pointing to
uh putin and going that guy's hitler i
mean i don't know he's a tyrannical
leader over russia and now he's imposing
himself on ukrainians is there anyone in
history who that just sounds like a
little bit more like besides hitler yeah
i mean he's an illiberal autocrat is the
word to describe illiberal illiberal
autocrat right he's a dictator who's not
he's not really keen on elections but
he's not hitler there's actual nazis
we're funding and backing this sounds
like the overthrow of the shah and iran
when we put the ayatollah in power and
it was like a radical from what i've
learned and maybe you can enlighten me
it's a radical islamic regime in power
because we wanted it to fight and dis
destabilize the region but then it ended
up destabilizing the whole world
from my perspective more modern it's
it's syria that was 79. it's the same
and some people some people say look
your country's been invaded everyone
should fight we don't care if they're
nazis and my point is if they're look
every country has racist and every
country has nazis and every country has
jihadist extremists but if you organize
them into a formal battalion that's the
equivalent so the analogy is false there
with saying every country has racists
the equivalent analogy is the u.s armed
force is having a formal kkk battalion
with kkk flags as part of the army
that's the analogy right it's shocking
if the us did that if the uk did that
people would be up in arms but we're
funding it in ukraine and and how come
uh many of these woke
youtubers and personalities who have no
problem in fact monetize
attacking nazis are now uh very much in
favor of our support of these groups in
ukraine but right so listen like uh
promoting a white man at work is deemed
racist but literally funding an actual
nazi armed battalion
is is fine the enemy of my enemy is my
friend so they say i'm not a fan of that
idea if they're going to say that then
i'm going to hold them to their word and
say so why is it wrong to fund isis in
syria and go and join them we've got
we've got uk media calling for british
citizen volunteers to go and join the
foreign legion in ukraine and join these
people so hang on a minute so when young
muslim men went to join isis in syria
that's terrorism but you can go and join
a nazi brigade in ukraine it's because
public perception
they look uh isis somehow managed to get
i think the famous image was like a
detroit plumbing company pickup truck in
syria or whatever and everyone's like
how did they get this how did how were
what these weapons being given to many
of these rebel groups ultimately then
you know becoming isis and it's because
i think it's fair to say correct me if
i'm wrong the u.s wants to dece if the
us wants to destabilize a region they
provide material support to insurgent
groups or extremist groups who then
create problems well and so then that
begs the question what's going on in
ukraine really like why have we been
funding armed nazi battalions who have
now been incorporated into the uh
ukrainian regime what's going on i i
feel like it's it wouldn't be out of the
question and far be it for me i'm not an
expert um
i think it's possible the country splits
in half yeah so i spent some time uh
during my dan i was in i went to ukraine
and i got to meet people
and uh talk to them everybody down there
was pro-eu they said getting access to
the schengen zone getting access to the
european union means a better economy
and russia wants them to join the trade
federation which is similar but much
weaker and smaller and it was a bad deal
for ukrainians not to mention a lot of
people i talked to said honestly we're
scared of what russia would do if
they're given power over us because we
saw what happened last time they had
power over us holla d'amour so there
many of these people especially in kiev
were very much like rather be with
europe sorry it seems like the us has
been using influence tactics bribery
manipulation like we saw with joe biden
if you don't if you don't fire the
prosecutor you don't get the billion
dollar guaranteed loans which is is
criminal and he admitted to it uh it was
influence tactics but the bribes the
cash the money it works putin didn't
have that apparently they didn't care
enough but like you mentioned the regime
change in 2014 the president yanukovych
was effectively ousted fled the country
went to russia the new government comes
in very pro-west so russia loses because
of that protest and now it seems his
only option it seems to be a last resort
physical invasion well why
why was why was that so important to him
after he lost is is really interesting
most of germany's gas comes through
ukraine yeah and that's why he was
building nordstrom 2 to go through the
black sea to bypass because if you think
about it
sorry the baltic sea yeah if you think
about it he had the access through
ukraine he loses that and so he tries to
build north stream too to go straight to
germany that gets thwarted
now he's got a problem by trump exactly
right interesting right right now he's
got a problem that he he's lost he's
lost the gas going through ukraine
because the regime's changed he can't
build it through the sea
but he need but he but he's got he's the
second largest oil producer in the world
now if you want to understand you know
in terms of if americans want to want to
understand how that feels
when ukraine was lost
as in putin lost ukraine it went into
the american sphere of influence
you end up with calls for it to join
nato
and not from 1997 the expansion of of
nato eastwards has incorporated most of
those countries but ukraine is right on
the border with russia so if you go back
to the cuban missile crisis and you
remember what it felt like for kennedy
to have those missiles pointed out
america from from cuba just 100 or so
miles away
putin's got to a point where saying
you're building
bases on my border you're asking for
nato membership and this is my backyard
why could ukraine not have stayed stayed
neutral that's the geopolitical conflict
that's going on i think that's part of
it but latvia and estonia are nato
members and they and they're on the
border uh with russia it was according
to scott horton who was just on kennedy
nation he was saying that it was
condoleezza rice that got them into nato
and put long-range tomahawk missile
nuclear yeah but they didn't have the
gas going through them exactly so i this
you know one of the things i've been
saying is
there's the belief that um a lot of
people have a lot of people believe the
conspiracy theory vladimir putin is
fighting klaus schwab in the world
economic forum in the new world order
you had that um that ukrainian member of
parliament who said that we're fighting
for a new world order and so there are
people who believe that there's this
great global battle in putin is defying
it and i'm like putin just wants to make
sure he's getting the proper resources
in exchange for the oil he produces so
that he can fund his country i wonder do
you think he has a some sort of issue
with the world economic forum and
he was on their website he was a member
so i i don't know if i don't know if
that holds up because he was a member
himself and they've just taken his
profile off oh wow switzerland they just
removed him switzerland is no longer
neutral they finally declared
non-neutrality in a war for the first
time i've ever seen and that's what the
bank of international settlements is
which is the central bank of central
banks yeah well what what i can say is
that when you cancel russia from swift
and visa and mastercard what you are
doing is precipitating
the the the need for
um for for russia to develop its own
financial system now when you when you
kick russia out of that uh that could
lead to a run on russian banks and if
there's a run on russian banks if
germany as it is is dependent on russian
gas that will have a knock-on effect on
germany's economy and he could end up
with weimar style uh hyperinflation uh
that could lead to in russia uh in but
not just russia outside of russia
because germany relies on russian gas so
energy prices spike we're already seeing
that and that's how much for gas out
here yeah yeah so the huge spike in
energy prices has an open effect to the
point where stagflation uh really pretty
much ends up destroying uh the currency
so it could end up being used regardless
of whether it's planned or not i tend
not to go into intentions i just look at
reality and describe it and say this is
what's happening so you could end up
with a scenario where because of
stagflation uh the dollar as a global
reserve currency comes under intense
pressure and it's that moment that is
used as an opportunity to switch over to
uh central banking digital currencies
well so so let me ask you
what is the relevance of vladimir putin
being kicked out of the uh
removed from the world economic forum
website i mean
we're talking about financial currencies
we're talking about the world economic
forum
it feels like i've got a bunch of points
that seem like they're connected the
world economic forum the international
monetary fund the swift payment system
russia being uh you know starting a war
then being booted what's what's the
connection here i mean was russia
involved in the liberal economic order
is he not involved in that or i don't
think putin is but but but i think that
this will be an opportunity for
the introduction of it potentially could
be i should say for the introduction of
central banking digital currencies um
which i describe as vouchers but it's
it's if that's
it sounds like
what putin is doing is going to help
make that a reality yeah
so it sounds like
that makes it sound like it's one big
plot well you don't need to i see this
is the thing we don't need to worry
about intentions just to understand what
the consequences of these actions are
yeah i agree and that's where people get
stuck they get stuck on intentions and
i'm like well
it doesn't matter what putin intended if
the consequences of kicking russia out
of the swift system mean that you end up
with this financial money supply
division on the planet you then have got
these blocks eurasia and oceana
and and what that leads to is if you can
no longer trade with russian banks when
you're buying russian gas in your
germany and you can no longer buy from
russia because you can't pay them
bitcoin you
and already we see bitcoin flooding into
ukraine to fund the opposition right
now how do you control that because
one thing we do know is bitcoin isn't in
the interests of the banking
establishment so that that's where you
then where is it
well you tell me i don't i think that
what they would want to do is introduce
central banking digital currencies
that's what they've told us they want
yeah i think there's a good possibility
when you look at the prominence of
bitcoin
over the past 10 years
it would not be hard for a
nation to gain enough control over the
network to create faux centralization
a lot of people say oh that can't happen
i don't believe it but um what's what's
the current market cap for bitcoin do
you know is it one trillion i guess is
2.1 trillion let's find out no it's
gonna be less than 1.9 trillion you
could have market manipulation right yep
you can manipulate the market there we
we absolutely do china's been doing that
it's 1.93 trillion 1.9 that's the global
market cap of all crypto right now of
all crypto so bitcoin market cap is 832
billion 832 billion so let's go back
seven years the market cap of crypto was
substantially less
the us nato countries could have easily
bought in and controlled more than 51 of
the bitcoin network which would give
them
control over how it works effectively
it's a little bit more complicated
though i'm trying to simplify it the
fact the point is
it just requires immense
uh managerial power but from the early
stages we could see the true power of
bitcoin i've long speculated and even
told all of my crazy anarchist and
libertarian friends i'm like
what if what if you know you're buying
into bitcoin
what if that's the global currency it's
public ledger anyone can track they the
ai systems their computers they'll
figure out what your address is
in seconds and there's nothing you can
do to stop them
you know i got to tell you man i have
seen brilliant
private investigatorial work from
individuals there there's a there's a an
individual who was doxed in the uk
uh he was posting on social media how
did they find out who he was
they knew how they knew the sound of his
voice
so they looked at the average they they
took a bunch of his posts and found the
average time of posting and they said
this shows the individual is in this
region of the uk
they then looked for a person who fit
key details background age interests
hobbies
a human being did all of that work
imagine what a computer can do when
you're doing transactions they'll
instantly know what part of the world
you're in from there they break it down
they know what you're buying because
they know what everyone else is buying
the bitcoin ledger is going it is it is
publicly trackable and when they talk
about zcash and monero which are two
cryptos which are supposedly secure we
learned that the fbi was able to track
monero payments when they arrested that
uh that woman crocodile of wall street
lady
yeah i i think there's i'm not saying
i'm a big fan of bitcoin so you're
you're talking about the um
the privacy concerns on the ledger but
what you still can't do is control the
supplier and you can manipulate the
price you can control the supply of
bitcoin it's called a 51 percent attack
if you control it more now i mean the
the overall amount of bitcoin in the
world once once it hit its um maximum
cap right you can't just print more
bitcoin once that's done right right
right bitcoin like fiat currency but um
with a 51 attack you can effectively do
anything you want yeah so if you control
more than half of the nodes then you
basically tell the the fork what to do
now of course if you go too hard you'll
create a hard fork and it'll split the
the blockchain in half we've seen that
happen on accident before
what i'm saying is i don't know if it's
true a lot of people say no tim calm
down this can never happen but if the us
and western powers
or even china and russia
bought in very very early on and have
maintained growth of their of their uh
bitcoin nodes they could absolutely
control more than half the network which
gives them control of the entirety of
the system so i think what you're
describing
is the
um
compared to what can be done with fiat
money in a in a sovereign nation is
probably a less worse case scenario than
what we currently have with the control
of the money support that's right that's
horrible what's going on right now they
can print 800 billion of fiat and then
just buy all the bitcoin now there's
also concerns about um quantum computing
being able to crack private keys in
which case the system is just a facade
that that though could be met so quant
if when we reach quantum power in that
way and it's sustainable i think you you
also end up with quantum encryption that
can actually
so you the technology improves in its
encryption capabilities not just in its
hacking capabilities exactly quantum
resistance
right yeah so so um
the the bitcoin community that all the
people involved could choose to hard
fork on purpose with new resilience and
new technology i will say this it is my
personal opinion that bitcoin will
become a dominant global standard for
exchange and store of value in some
meaningful way i've i've long thought
that was the case and that's why i've
said how do you know this is not the
global currency that's something they
want but i'll put it i'll put it very
simply i've long said i believe one
bitcoin will become worth a million
dollars equivalent buying power
i believe we're on track for that i
don't know exactly when or how but i do
believe that and i have certainly bought
my share of bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
because i truly believe it i'm not
telling anybody what to do i'm just
saying what i've done i believe there
comes a time where watching what's
happening in russia every incentive is
being given to them to back their
financial markets using bitcoin as the
facilitation mechanism or yeah that's
the consequence of what's happening or a
central bank token which is worse than
well it's different than a crypto
because it's not on a blockchain it's
just a central bank they have it on a
ledger but it's a digital currency that
they can track it's uh that's a disaster
i know because i could tell you from
there this is what i'm worried about
because i could say right uh
you're not going to buy meat this week
you've had your quota which you can't
even if you can manipulate the bitcoin
uh price if you control 51
what you can't do is say right you can't
use the tiny bit of bitcoin that you own
to buy that meat you have to buy bugs it
depends on if they can gain control of
the exchanges which they mostly can
[Music]
so uh
if people are i'll put it this way they
can ban your address from sending or
receiving through certain exchanges so
they can say all of our financial
institutions and mechanism the companies
that facilitate the exchange we won't
allow it but the blockchain still exists
which means you could easily find
someone who just says i'll do a direct
adjustment transfer outside they could
do something like a centrally controlled
economy could do something where if you
have crypto you have to buy nfts as
vouchers and then you use those nfts for
specific things so you can only use
those nfts for food for liquor
the currency would need to be fungible
but they can control the system it
doesn't need to be you know unique
tokens specifically right i think this
is the this is the so we've got the
chancellor of exchequer in the uk rishi
sonak openly declaring this uh uh
that as the leader of the g7 they're
going to introduce central banking
digital currencies right and these as
this is what i'm calling as vouchers
and uh you so
the fiat money pretty much at some stage
is going to come to an end and what
you've described as the potential
dangers and pitfalls of bitcoin
specifically or crypto generally i still
think is a least worst case scenario
when you can consider what can happen i
agree with cbdc it sounds like i just
want to say real quick um i'm i'm sort
of playing devil's advocate on the
potential risks of bitcoin i genuinely
think it's it's better it's i think it's
fantastic and i think it's going to
become a million dollars per bid it's
good that you're doing it because it's
like don't let a crisis go to waste and
what's happening is the bankers are
looking at bitcoin as a crisis and
they're trying to make sure that they
can turn it into an opportunity just
like joe biden encouraged us to do last
night on this in his campaign speech
they called it a state of the union it
was just campaign speech at the very
news like and what by the way the state
of the union the state of the union is
strong
the state of the union is strong because
the people are strong and then strong
strong strong everyone's like yeah
and we're gonna end cancer do you see
that joke where you gotta watch it at
the end
at the end he says go get him and
everyone's like what like what does that
mean yeah who who who's that and then
he's inciting an insurrection someone
that's during the standing ovation
wasn't it
yeah and then someone uh someone i think
from the daily wire said that was just
the part that of the of the prompter
that biden wasn't supposed to read it
was instructions to his handlers
go get him that's hilarious we were
debating if he said uh when he was
saying the ukrainian people at one point
he said the uranium people and people
like
iranians the closest the closest real
word to the sound he made is iranian but
it sounded like uranian so i was making
fun of like you talking about uranus i i
think you're right that's how i say it
he said iranian
russia will never get the hearts and
minds of the of the iranian people the
iranian people nobody never said they
never outside but here's here's here's
the important oh yeah
talk back about him splitting the cup
why why do we believe he meant to say
ukrainian
who
is the person who gets to decide what
joe biden really meant
if joe biden so he was meeting with the
g7 and he said you know we got you know
troops in libya we're going to be
sending military he meant syria
what would happen what would happen if
joe biden's in a you know a a situation
room meeting and he's like uh we we got
to send these weapons to the iranian
people and then someone was like are you
mr president are you sure yeah we're
we're going to send 30 billion dollars
some uh some fighter jets to the iranian
people and they'll go
whatever you say sir i'll make it happen
and then breaking news iran receives
massive payload of cash from us
government dude it's not even a joke but
hold on imagine the alternative joe
biden says we're going to send a pallet
of cash to the ukrainian people and
someone goes he meant iranian people and
then they decide for themselves and
exactly when they when it's hitting the
fan and it's wartime make a decision now
and he says the wrong word that's death
but that's why it's so dangerous to have
a president that effectively is is
mentally impaired no and he actually no
we were talking about the most polite
way i've ever it's a very polite way of
putting it and we were sort of joking
about this the other day we were
watching his state of the union poking
fun at him it is actually genuinely sad
the fact that we were all
talking about this after the show this
is probably the best speech he's given
in his entire presidency and he's
slurring every single word he sounds
intoxicated
yeah and that's as good as it gets i
mean i remember for him when trump would
give speeches and make such mistakes
there would be viral videos exactly and
they were never even close to as bad as
biden's mistakes like biden's best and
i'm not saying trump didn't have some
gaps but like biden's best day is what
we saw yesterday and he sounded drunk he
really did i'm not trying to be mean and
if anyone's going to come at me and say
that that's really insensitive to say
about the president of the united states
you are acknowledging that he did sound
like that oh that's a good point
he did realistically now i want to just
touch back on ukraine really quick so
you think that he's going to try and i
think i've been thinking almost every
day he's going to split the country in
half on that river yeah that reservoir
you know what the name of the river is i
can't figure it out it's such a
reservoir referred as upper river but
who knows papa but there's the east and
the west right so the side that's on the
russian side
that's the east of that river we'll
probably go to look i say probably let's
hope there's no world war three right so
if look ultimately putin's gone in there
now and he's not just gonna leave that
right he's gone in there for a reason
for whatever reason so probably this is
the the outcome that it will end on
which is that you'd end up with a split
ukraine
and kiev like the kievan ruse i think
that was the history of the russians was
kievan kevin russ yeah and it's in his
backyard right so
you know beta pigs i mean america's done
all of this stuff
iran contra affair
you know i know i wanna i wanna speak
out against it but like
to sit in silence while my brethren are
conquering and kicking doors in iraq is
i don't know if they're still doing that
but they were if our president is uh as
you described it mentally impaired
indeed yes can't speak straight
how is he going to prevent russia from
doing whatever it is russia intends to
do
is it because if someone else is in
charge no but he's not going to
he's if you know what has he done i mean
look well they cancelled this icbm test
which is
in some ways go but that's not
preventing russia that's just not
escalating a conflict right which is
good by the way i'm happy but
no one's going to stop what putin's
decided to do unless you want war with
putin and this is the problem that
you've got an option right now putin
went in and called everybody's bluff now
either we engage directly with russia
and that's world war three which i don't
think is a good idea
in particular because we don't have the
moral high ground you know our own
countries have gone and invaded
countries
and when we went into iraq and
afghanistan the last thing we expected
um
was for russia to attack us directly
because we invaded iraq or afghanistan
you know what narrative i really love
yeah there's a story coming out where it
said vladimir putin believed the
invasion would last only 15 days and the
government would collapse and uh they
would come in and it would be clean and
i was like yeah yeah yeah and and we
thought we'd be greeted as liberators
the same same narrative this is it it
says people are very very out of touch
and they they
i find it amazing how um there is now
almost it's expected that we take a line
on this that is uh this word jingoism
right it's very jingoistic line that
we're expected to take almost as if we
must
uh back direct
action against against russia so that
question on on your point that question
that the journalists put to um to boris
johnson when he was in poland i say
journalist
it was somebody purporting to be a
journalist who started well let's let's
let's let's get into this yeah should i
put it up
so i have this here from the week yeah
take a look at this story
ukrainian journalist confronts boris
johnson nato is afraid of world war iii
but it has already started this was a a
ukrainian journalist
daria kaliniak who had fled ukraine and
was calling on the uk to enforce a
no-fly zone
as soon as you announce a no-fly zone
you're declaring war yeah you are
literally declaring why why there
because you shoot down a plane
russian jets
but it's a declaration of war because
you are saying to the other country we
are going to figurative declaration no
we gotta get away from misusing the word
literal well only congress can declare
war literally no no no no no no that's
legally you're talking about legal yeah
i'm talking about liberal liberal i'm
talking about a literal declaration of
war not a legal one unless you don't
enforce the no-fly zone if you're
enforcing a no-fly zone you have to
shoot russian russian jets down in
ukrainian airspace the minute you do
that it's an act of war well it's an act
of war but to put it this way it would
be like me saying
sheamus
if you take one step you know in that
direction i'm going to you know we'll
hit you or push you or something i have
declared my intent to attack him that's
that's that's that's not legal yeah and
you right
declaration of war is a specific thing
no no no put yourself in a situation in
the united states in the united states
there's certain
statutes about declaration of war
completely irrelevant to the actual to
actual war you come people come out here
and they talk about war crimes and all
of this stuff and i'm like these are
like rules put in place by european
councils and conventions to be like dare
i say we shouldn't use this kind of
weapon okay that would be a crime you
wanna talk about real war declaring war
is me saying i am going to shoot you if
you do this no that we did that in
vietnam it wasn't war though it wasn't
an official war it was just the military
yeah well there was conflict in combat
but it wasn't technically i'm going to
say it one more time because i don't
want to get into that you guys look it
up i'm not lying about it no i i hear
what you're saying about the legal
defense you don't understand you're
talking about an american legal
president i'm not i'm talking about
literal reality
that if you are a country of any type
with regardless of your laws and you say
i intend to shoot you out of the sky you
have declared war against i think war is
a specific term that's that's used in
times of like
specific types of conflict like combat
destruction and conflict doesn't have to
be a war but can you see what he's
saying that if if you shot russian jets
down for example and then russia shot
your your jets down in response and then
you started nuking each other even if
congress didn't declare war you're in i
was going to swear
on earth you're in war right if you're
doing well even if congress soldiers
would call it that and they'd say war is
his point
we're not talking about the united
states
the u.s has nothing to do with this stop
thinking about the u.s
if the if the uk says to russia we
intend to shoot you out of the sky they
have declared war against them i don't
know about any legal parliamentary
status about other countries irrelevant
if i am if if my neighbor
is next to me and i tell him if you put
a drone in the sky you know i'll uh
throw a water balloon at it i have
declared my intent to take action
against him should he do something i
don't like now that's what the i'm going
to say journalist advisedly this lady uh
daria kulanick that you've referenced up
there
she called on boris johnson when he was
in poland the uk prime minister to
declare a no-fly zone over ukraine which
would mean we would declare to russia
we're going to shoot you down if you fly
over ukraine right which is an act of
war now it turns out that this person
who called themselves a journalist who
stood up in this press conference
is actually a member of the world
economic forum this is their profile on
the wef website um if you look up their
name and wef you can see it on your
screen there there they are and actually
the bio does not state journalists
it doesn't state journalists it states
daria is co-founder and executive
director of the anti-corruption action
center a powerful national organization
that has shaped ukraine's
anti-corruption legislation and efforts
by the way anti-corruption became an
agenda because of course the
biden-affiliated biden-aligned uh
america-friendly regime there was
accused of corruption so they set up an
anti-corruption unit to investigate
themselves this was it now this person's
called themselves a journalist and stood
up
calling for boris johnson to enforce a
no-fly zone uh over uh over ukraine to
declare war
declaration of war it's very interesting
to me that they are a member of the uh
world economic forum
yeah i i i have strong opinions on
ukraine and what joe biden did and uh
and hunter
and hunter um and it's all part of the
it's all one big happy family tree son
as they all uh collude to engage in a
tree zone but uh uh
charity call yeah the world economic
forum has plainly uh stated that they
want they don't think uh nationalist
governments are capable of governing the
world in its current form but we need
some sort of hybrid corporate governance
with and i think that they're trying to
get countries to blow themselves up so
that they can show that oh yeah you do
need our help to come in and save the
day build back better yeah you got to
destroy before you can build back that's
the point so who is what's a great reset
you have to destroy everything first you
have to reset it and then build back
better so i wonder why certain voices in
the media and you see them openly
encouraging war with russia
and i wonder what what do you want to
build back from the ashes of this war
once you've had your way and that's why
it becomes so important to make sure
they don't get their way there's a great
meme are you familiar with the political
compass no
so uh the political compass is you've
got the authoritarian on top the
libertarian on the bottom oh yeah yeah
okay yeah i am familiar so you have the
authoritarian left you know i thought
you saw a band or something no no
you have the authoritarian right you
know fascists traditionalists uh the
meme shows
it's the wojack meme you know it's a bit
paintbrush kind of guy with the squiggly
face and like the evil eyes and each
quadrant is looking towards the center
the f the far left libertarian the far
libertarian the far left authoritarian
and far right authoritarian are all
looking down at the story of world war
three saying i can't wait for the world
to collapse so i can rebuild this world
in my image yeah
they all believe it and and look there's
a problem here which is that
some way or the other whether it's by
enforcing a no-fly zone in um in ukraine
or it's by directly arming and funding
nazis i worry about the stability of
europe so i'm going to pull something up
for you um i wonder if lydia you can you
can look this up
let me what's that so there's a new york
times article
let me just find the headline for you so
you can search for it give me a second
and what while i'm looking for it what
it's basically uh
what it's talking about is that because
of this as of battalion that has now
been raised in ukraine um already we
know that internationally so i've done a
lot of work in counter radicalization
and counter extremism
um before being a broadcaster i founded
an organization called quilliam which
was a counter extremism right
organization seeking to help understand
during the global war and terror how to
navigate our way through that
from a muslim background especially
because of course
muslims were central to that debate so
i come at this from that uh from that
angle when when i look at radicalization
understanding how radicalization can
work so if you've got a if you've got an
armed nazi battalion that gains victory
in ukraine what that does to
radicalization is incredibly dangerous
and there's a new york times article uh
that actually
uh addresses the fact that people now
neo-nazis have been traveling from
around the world
flocking to the as of battalion to join
them now once you have co so think um
think isis and al-qaeda and how global
jihadism
uh if you had a battlefield how foreign
fighters would go they'd fight with that
jihadist group and then they'd hey you
got it i didn't even have to find it for
you yeah i'm pretty good at google i
suppose uh far-right militias in europe
plan to confront russian forces a
research group says right so they're
flocking to join as of right now now the
problem here is what does that do
for radicalization if you end up
traveling across europe to join the as
of battalion you gain combat experience
fighting the russians and then you go
back to your country of origin
right you're now the equivalent of the
jihadi foreign fighter now we know what
effect that had with global jihadism
those that fought in afghanistan against
the soviet union
when the soviets occupied afghanistan
al-qaeda emerged from there global
jihadism spread from that combat
experience in afghanistan 9 11 happened
and the rest is history this is the
powder keg we've currently got what
happens though in europe in particular
is very interesting combine this new
york times article with the fact that
the video in fact you could probably
still pull up the video of the um
official ukrainian national guard
posting that video uh of the as of
battalion guy dipping bullets in
pigslard and the reason why that's
important it's lard is everything yeah
pig's lard right pig fat so i'm gonna um
if you can't find it because it's on
twitter you may not be able to find it
but i'll find it as well and then just
at least what we can do is because the
audio he actually uses the word in their
language he uses the word muslims why
that's relevant is combine these two
pieces of news together you've got the
potential for foreign fighter
radicalization
this time with nazism as opposed to
jihadism on european soil but europe's
never had more muslim citizens in
history than it currently has think
france for example 10 muslim
also europe has a radicalization problem
on the muslim side now going going back
to the great reset and the destruction
of the world order and build back better
this is the perfect way to encourage
civil war in europe with these
battle-hardened nazi fighters going back
to their currencies of origin you've got
jihadis there already keep in mind the
chechens who are in ukraine at the
behest of putin
is who the azov battalion was talking
about when they said they were going to
dip their bullets in pig's lard to shoot
church and muslims now the problem here
you got is so they've gone to fight
muslims in chechen muslims in ukraine
they come back to their countries of
origin and they find islamist muslims in
their own countries of origin what i
worry about
is this leading
to radical reciprocal radical
radicalization in european countries and
that civil conflict emerging in
continental europe one of the most uh
valuable things any great reset is a
civil war yeah exactly right and and
it's incredibly worrying because we've
already had a genocide in europe in
bosnia with muslims and you end up with
with this situation
and and you know we've been funding
these we've been funding this nazi
battalion what was the bosnian genocide
it was it was a genocide against bosnia
muslims when during the bosnian war
1990s early 90s and how many people died
so in srebrenica and this rabbinica
massacre you had i think it was 6 000
bosnian muslim men and boys she is in
one day in a mass grave in one attack
wow yeah
this was just the bosnian government or
was it this is the sub serbian croatian
bosnian so the the the former sort of so
there was interestingly the olympics
were also ahead they're held there just
before this happened the olympics always
get involved in these sorts of things
remember hitler had the olympic games as
well
it's crazy but yeah it and this is in
living memory by the way right so this
is when so when i was 15
and 14 this genocide was happening and
it radicalized an entire generation of
european muslims oh well this is when i
was 12 and i remember clinton the
bosnian war was all about serbia
and so he sent troops in to stop the
genocide was that the intent that's so
kosovo came immediately after that and
so he sent troops in the the ostensible
declared attempt intent was to stop it
happening again in kosovo where albanian
muslims were just after the bosnia
genocide but the date and accords is
what emerged from that yeah it's
clinton's date and accords and they did
that tournament in nato or something the
dayton accords i don't know about this
so so the dated accords was a deal that
he struck um with the serbs involving
the kosovans to stop the war
uh expanding into kosovo but the
genocide had already happened by then i
want to talk about uh manipulation of
propaganda yeah if we can so i have this
uh this tweet from me
you are being played they are
manipulating your emotions to get you to
support war
in the first clip you can see emotional
moment german interpreter cries during
zelinski's speech then you have this
tweet cnn interpreter cries as he
translates zelinski's speech that
mentions children killed by russian
strikes
and then you have another story
translator breaks down during photo
mirza lenski speech to european
parliament i i do believe it's not uh i
believe it's two interpreters but i
posted these three stories because of
the ones i just happen to have um
my my intent to what to explain here is
not so much that there are uh there are
two different circumstances i found
where translators began crying that is
wholly inappropriate in my opinion and i
believe it's propaganda and manipulation
not necessarily intentional or whatever
but i think they allow these things to
happen they they know these things are
going to happen because what they want
is
when the president of ukraine is giving
a speech talking about the devastation
and uh speaking
literally about what's happening
children are dying we need to push back
on this
to drive the point home in terms of
manipulating emotions you have someone
cry while saying it which the president
of ukraine certainly was not doing
this is a manipulation of your emotions
to hear someone
so you go oh no they're crying they want
you to support ground war in ukraine and
why
why
i mean well this comes back to what i'm
saying right well why would you want to
do that
military industrial complex profits no
but you know it's going to spark
i guess who's the they and the major
world region there's there i think for
me it's always a simple solution of who
benefits and it's um weapons
manufacturers uh stocks skyrocketed the
moment war was declared and you know it
and they they actually did that article
10 it was like see digital security
firms
there's an article that said um what was
it uh cutting russia off from the swift
payment system could result in major
cyber attacks here are some stocks that
will greatly improve or you know will go
up in value and it's like
basically saying invest in these
companies
so lydia what i've just done is i've
just emailed you the um the video that
i'm talking of of the as of fighters
doing that
i couldn't send you the tweet because
twitter has decided that this tweet very
dangerous violence
is it on your twitter no it's still on
twitter but you can't tweet it out you
can't retweet it or send it to somebody
but because i quote because i quote
tweeted it i've sent you my quotes okay
well who who posted it the the
international you quote tweeted it so
the national uh guard of ukraine posted
the video oh this is the pig's blood one
yeah yeah i'm looking at it now
yeah and so i because i quote tweeted i
can send you my quote tweet which allows
you but i couldn't send the actual when
did you post it uh on the um
27th of february maybe you can help
because i i'm did you
let me let me let me do this what did
you say in the quote tweet do you want
me to email it to you no no just tell me
what it was i can pull it up
i've said why does the national guard of
ukraine think it acceptable to glorify
the nazi as of brigade while they grease
bullets with lard
to target kadyrov's chechen forces
i'm sorry your country was attacked me
but arm nazi units are not an answer
especially when pulling off this i i i
gotta say i don't know if youtube would
uh consider it a violation of the rules
if we show that video but twitter did
but let's see
if you clicked view you can see if you
hit view the video will come up because
it's not been banned
my concern is that youtube will delete
the live stream we should definitely
show this on the after show regardless
we'll show it on the in fact we'll have
a conversation about religion and the
implications but uh this is one of the
problems of propaganda manipulation and
censorship and it's why they need
censorship i'm i i actually believe if
we were to show that video youtube would
probably just take the stream down yeah
that's a strike block us from streaming
because it's bad for the establishment
narrative and yet and yet it's
newsworthy to know that that's what the
formal ukrainian army has tweeted out
with our funding and backing hunter
biden's laptop was particularly
newsworthy and they shut that down this
is the first moment i've seen him turn
into a religious war of any type yeah
they're going after their faith right
and then why am i raising that's the
point why i'm raising this is because
those that new york times article you
pulled up to him right so those fighters
now let's call them foreign fighters a
bit like we call foreign fighters
foreign fighters right they go to join
that battalion they've gone and they
know they're targeting chechen muslims
they get radicalized their nazis they go
back to france 10 of france is muslim
yeah
and france has its own muslim
radicalization problem and france as we
know and if you read any of welbeck for
example his book submission we know what
could potentially happen with that
tension and i worry that you end up with
this perfect storm
and you end up with a civil conflict in
europe and of course if you need to
build back better you need your great
reset you can't build back unless
there's unless there's a great reset
both of those phrases happen to come
from something
in the united states there's a
escalating concern of a civil conflict
here as well yeah and i i certainly feel
like it's um
like it's coming i saw a story of google
pay and apple pay uh banned russia they
don't you can't use it in russia to get
on the subway anymore so the lines are
really long so i was thinking the cost
the cost is not only fiscal but it's
time if you can't get to where you're
going in time then you can't get it done
in time which means it doesn't get done
right which is another kind of cost that
you gotta that's right but let's push
this a bit right so
um who why would you have a policy of
divide and conquer in this way yeah why
do you want me hating you guys
right muslim hating non-muslims
if you're if your system is under threat
as we know from the british empire
the best way to make sure that all of us
are not looking up
is to make sure we're looking left and
right that's critical race theory
correct
and that's what i believe if you look at
the situation with the money supply if
you look at like what's going on with um
this desire to to have this great reset
the only thing that makes sense is to
encourage everybody to turn on each
other and we witness that happening
we witness that happening in our media
narratives you know there's a reason why
the word racism is now being thrown
around everywhere by not by you or me
but by big corporations
who you know you think about it what why
have they suddenly become so interested
in stoking these racial fires
what's going on and these are some of
the biggest profit making corporations
on the planet why why is it the people
who were
supporting the rise over black lives
matter who then became the vaccine
mandate supporters are now the flag they
keep changing the emojis in their
twitter accounts and if you follow us
like they're not they're they're they're
not uh um
independently thinking individual
prioritizing profit overall else maybe
but if you follow the causes they've
supported one thing you can see from
those causes is they all do end up
dividing everybody from each other to a
point where people are fighting each
other
yeah
rage bait why
hate clicks emotions put people in a
vulnerable place and then you can get
them do what you want them to do and
they're emotionally erratic a little
easier push this button now you're
better
you know i wonder if um
some people are just not able to be
independent thinkers that that's what i
should say some people are leaders some
people are followers there's nothing
wrong with being a follower some people
just want to you know get by and live an
honest life and have someone else be
more dedicated to the the hard decisions
i can understand that but if that's the
case that means there are a lot of
people who are going to say something as
absurd as
you know you you don't even got to do
anything you just look it up on the
cdc's website just do whatever they tell
you which in my opinion is an absurd
statement i mean you have to take some
responsibility for your own life when
you get a follower in a leadership
position like when someone says that
dumb follower mine but they have a
hundred thousand people listening to
them like they're leading follower leads
the followers then you get that's a good
it's a good example of of you know like
these uh these podcasters who have said
you don't even got to think about it
just do what the government tells you or
who have um
they're followers who have been put in
you know high up positions where all
they're doing is telling their followers
to follow other people to do as they're
told basically because they themselves
are followers
i think i think there's a the the the
average person is working nine to five
who's struggling monday to friday to put
bread on the table for them and their
family
i can excuse them right they don't have
the time luxury or privilege to think
through some of these topics
what i am particularly animated about is
those people that do have the time
luxury and privilege to think through
this stuff and still choose to do
uh
still choose
a course of action that harms people
severely because they want to make money
and profit i know or well i i would say
there's also something else on top of
that i agree with you
but i would argue that in most
situations it's just the fact that they
don't want to think too hard about
things because then they face social
ostracism so if you're an academic and
you're out of line with the other
academics and question their orthodoxy
all of a sudden you're less likely to
get a promotion you're not getting
invited out and you're just not liked by
your friends which is really painful for
us as human beings so i think oftentimes
it isn't necessarily just a profit
motive it's about social status yeah
yeah yeah
it's funny that um
the people who throw on the word grifter
tend to be the grifters mm-hmm it's
projection isn't it because the thief
thinks everyone steals you know you get
to compete
well let me let me elaborate on this
people base the people think everyone
else
thinks and behaves the way they do
so what's interesting is you know i i
don't see you accusing left-wing
personnel as of being grifters um
i maybe uh periodically might say i
believe someone's ingenuous or grifting
but uh for the most part the politically
homeless the post-liberal
the freedom faction whatever you want to
call it aren't going around saying this
leftist personality is a grifter for
money
but the leftist personalities say it all
day every day they make shows and
segments just targeting people on the
opposite side of the political spectrum
and say they're grifting for money i
also i think it's a genuine failure to
understand human motivation in most
cases i think if somebody believes
something that
they haven't really looked deeply enough
into to have a fast fact based opinion
on it's not so much because they're
trying to cynically exploit people for
gain that can happen but i really think
often times it's because they settle
down a particular perspective they're
afraid of looking into it more deeply
they do believe that they're right and
that they're telling the truth but
they're not responsible in their pursuit
of it and so they end up promoting
things they shouldn't be promoting and
saying things that aren't true and they
do end up making money off of that but
it's not as if they're twirling their
mustache going i'm actually
a right winger and i'm making money as a
left-wing pundit or vice versa i i've
said something uh uh something and we
saw um
who was it who said this uh
i can't remember the the gentleman's
name i'm forgetting clifton duncan sorry
sorry what's up uh i think it was
clifton i could be wrong um but i said
something the effect of
you know the people who know what's
going on
they but they're but they're unwilling
to stand up and take responsibility and
do anything about it are part of the
problem but i believe it was clifton it
could be wrong if it wasn't forgive me
who said
that um he's starting to have more
contempt for those people that was close
then it was clifton yeah then which
people then the people who are just like
mindless drones is a part of the woke so
the more contempt is for the ones who
know the ones who know but won't do
anything yeah well that's that's my
point that you can't look look you know
people living on minimum wage
people that are from say for example
migrant communities whose first language
is in english who are petrified that
they're going to get kicked out the
country if they step foot in the wrong
direction
there are excuses and understandable
reasons for why people may not be
engaged with controversial political
conversation but there are people that
have the luxury and the privilege to
engage in that and either don't say the
right thing or are actively saying and
doing the wrong thing and that's where i
think the focus needs to be go back to
that example
and you've got governments and by
definition that means people in power
funding arm nazi brigades now what that
does immediately is undo the entire last
12 years we put our we when i say we now
i'm talking about
muslims that put their neck on the line
to go and challenge a lot of the
extremism and terrorism that was coming
from our communities right we put our
neck on the line me and the networks
that i work with um that one of them was
meant to come here with me today but
paperwork and whatever uh usman my
brother usman rajo we do a lot of um for
example intervention work in prisons
with muslims who are convicted of
high-level terrorism through mentoring
through martial arts to attempt to
rehabilitate them now you put your neck
on the line for that kind of work and
you say to these people that there is
never an excuse for example to leave
your
democratic rights-based civil law based
country to go and join for example a
jihadi brigade in isis because you're
upset with assad that dictator right now
they're witnessing videos put out by
british media encouraging british
citizens to go to ukraine and join
that well that we just pulled up right
it's undone
all of the last 10 to 12 years and the
last point i'm making on this is that
back to that oceana discussion like
we are so unaware of how that's
perceived outside of our media matrix
the work that's been undone is to the
point now where you're going to have a
16 year old muslim based in france who's
going to see those nazis go and fight
with other nazis and say you know what
why am i i'm going to go and join
the chechens and fight these guys
because they're dipping bullets in
pigsled we've gone back to square one
i was invited by youtube to an
anti-extremism event the concern was
that um jihadi groups were using
youtube to recruit they were showing
videos they were claiming it was
injustice you to fight for justice and
they were talking about strategies to
stop this and it was particularly
particularly in the uk they said that
these groups were targeting kids in the
uk to convince them to go fight in these
wars i find it fascinating to bring up
now that it's effectively essentially
okay when it comes to ukraine well what
you've just said there right so i'm
going to pull uh something else up if my
if the wi-fi works heavy so if you if
you can pull that um tweet back up of
mine and go down it's a thread
so yeah scroll down
and uh there will be
a um
oh oh you have to log in okay
so what what what so there's an
intercept article i can talk you through
it there's an intercept article
basically facebook on that point yeah on
radicalization
facebook
has decided that it's prohibited to
promote the as of brigade because
they're neon nazis
unless you're promoting them to fight
russia
i saw that that's amazing isn't it now
this is the what i'm saying about the uh
again i'm trying not to swear right i'm
doing the work we've just done for 12
years on the muslim side imagine you're
a young
you know 16 year old french muslim right
and you see that imagine you're antifa
you were there man and you're and you're
screaming nazi for five years yeah and
then you're like finally we're getting
these people banned from facebook and
facebook goes whoa whoa whoa whoa we're
letting these guys back on i don't know
if people even know your history here it
is
do you see that facebook allows praise
of neo-nazi ukrainian battalion if it
fights russian invasion wow
i mean i can send it to you lydia if you
want to put it up but that's amazing was
that on twitter that's on intercept oh
the internet if you look if you look up
the intercept facebook allows praise of
neo-nazi ukrainian you'll get it on your
screen i just want people to see this
tim forgive me it's important because
it's the hypocrisy it stinks look at
that that's incredible and the problem
is whether you're antifa or a young
islamist right
the problem now is how are you going to
react to that
yeah let's let's let's talk about we're
going to do a
it's not a complete hard segue yeah this
has a lot to do with the great reset but
it's very strange this is a story from
timcast.com chile passes employment law
prohibiting discrimination against
mutations and alterations of genetic
material
have you heard this so employers can
only ask workers to undergo genetic
testing if it's necessary for their
safety
they say
the national congress of chile passed
the policy on february 16 114 votes and
no abstentions no employer may condition
the hiring of workers their permanence
or their renewal of their contract or
the promotion or mobility in their
employment to the absence of mutations
or alterations in their genome that can
cause a predisposition or a high risk of
pathology that may manifest itself
during the course of the employment
relationship now are they saying
is this let's just let's just be calm
for a second what is this are they
basically saying if you have like down
syndrome or a genetic disorder
the question is alterations to the
genome
what i find interesting is is this
specific line here a predisposition or
high risk of a pathology
so that's almost implying that an
alteration to your gene
or to your genome could end up with you
gaining this pathology you would not
have otherwise have had
what pathology is that that they're
saying that you could gain this is a
very very strange story what do we have
right now that is in any way
altering people's genomes precisely
wi-fi
no i'm just kidding right now i don't
know about g towers
no no but but
then everything but how does it even
that even the vaccines right which is
what you're really saying how does that
factor
how does that lead to a pathology like
this is what i think what what like
unless they're saying that there is a
connection between the whatever gene
therapy was in those vaccines to having
developed a pathology so is that an
admission i don't pathology is one of
the side effects i don't know um look
look nothing about this has anything to
do with the vaccine i think that what it
means if in case it leads to a pathology
and it was genetic they can't say you
can't work here because you're gonna
fall down a lot because you have this
gene no but it says it says it says
specifically right sorry to push this
guys no i watch right to the absence of
mutations or alterations in their genome
that cause a predisposition or a high
risk of a pathology now there's only
that first of all you're not going to
talk about alterations to the gene in a
vacuum or a void
what is it that we've taken recently
that causes an alteration yeah i've got
to look at horizontal gene transfer
the environment no no i don't i i think
i think we're more looking at
transhumanism in general yeah crispr
they're going in there and altering
genetics
but they're not doing that in chile
chile is actually one of the most
co-opted countries on earth right now i
i spent a couple of months down there
six months and i was learning like it's
the highest it's one of the uh most
copper rich countries in the world so
it's like military industrial complex
owns it now diet coke is in there making
people obese china absolutely is doing
china but
but what if you're what if you're uh one
of these chinese super uh ubermensch and
you and you go and do work no china's
doing tons of that's right and
development why randomly in chile
chilean's big business place right now i
don't know if a lot of people realize
yeah no no i i don't think the country
of origin matters so much as we know
china's been uh it's been reported by
numerous outlets been working on
ubermensch
superman super soldiers
and
this seems like
i gotta be honest it says alteration to
the genome
it sounds like they're preparing
because once you do that you're born
with the alteration right forever well
there's this thing guys.com says some
reporting of the bill's passage noted
that chile has been celebrated for its
high vaccination right but but again we
don't know whenever it comes to that
stuff just talk to a doctor we're not i
i think i don't i don't want to be too
myopic or you know what it's just weird
it's weird though you gotta admit well
the whole that's why absolutely that's
what i want to talk i just want to know
why now because i am not inclined to
believe it is because of the vaccination
but i'm very curious is a very strange
place and it is a strange time so i'm
wondering is it weak i think it's
transhumanists great reset oriented kind
of stuff so uh so why chile
because well i mean ian can give you an
example as you said it's a crop the
country but who cares if it's chile it
doesn't matter if it's chile what
matters is there is a country doing it
and there are countries like china that
do this kind of genetic modification and
alteration chile's like right on the
coast right up for china to just land on
and but regardless
if any company is doing work in this
country and they've passed this law
certainly something has occurred in this
country
to trigger the requirement of this law
so my question is who
well we know china's doing it i want to
get to the bottom of this what are they
doing the one thing we know is the super
soldier stuff yeah but does this mean
that in chile genetically engineered or
modified or altered humans are employed
at companies maybe i mean you wouldn't
have that introduced if there wasn't
that considerable something had to have
happened before they're preparing for
something what's interesting the
difference between change to your
genetic code and change to your genome
i don't know did you ask if there is or
you're saying no there's an interesting
difference right so the change to the
genome i believe is permanent in your
lineage forever
oh right right right whereas a change to
your genetic code in you just you it's
just you that's interesting because
change to your genome means your lineage
forever has that alternative there's
lateral gene transfer which is your
lineage and then there's horizontal gene
transfer which is your environment
changing your genetics what if what this
is this is where uh alex jones is
animal hybrid you know animal human
hybrids
i'm kidding but no no don't even joke
dude i remember the supreme court thing
like 2011 where they finally decided you
can patent life what yeah monsanto right
what if we've just gotten so progressive
that we're trying to protect the rights
of groups that don't even exist yet and
now every single country is going to try
to out progressive the last country by
being like yeah well this group that
doesn't even exist yet will be protected
you can't discriminate against giant
balloon gaseous orbs from outer space
no it has some grounding in reality yes
it might be right yeah you don't i
introduced that law
i hear you it's weird it's very fishy
have the right according to the world
health organization what does it say the
south american nation
has a has
had over three million cases of covet
19. see they're linking it to to covert
man well this is timcast.com and so i'm
wondering
i will absolutely criticize my own
website yeah
let's do that together right who wrote
it oh it's hannah claire brimello
santa clara's actually really really
good she's great but i but i i do think
we we have issues where um
i i personally would be very careful
about directly adding
a framing device such as hey look at all
the covet cases in this country i don't
see that as relevant to the passage of
this law
i i mean you speak to the whoever the i
mean i don't know the lady but why would
they have put that in there that's maybe
a conversation you need to have
absolutely oh we do have these
conversations rather than yeah this is
one that i just don't i'm not
comfortable talking about on youtube due
to terms and conditions but you know
when you're working with genetic uh
materials then what we're gonna say
magic no it's just it says it says um
similar in switzerland and austria
similar laws protecting the genetic
characteristics of workers had already
been passed in switzerland and austria
but is but again this the question here
is um are they referring to someone who
might have down syndrome right like you
can't discriminate against someone with
down syndrome it sounds like they are no
but then but then you just say you don't
discriminate against people that have
disabilities
why would you need it
because in a progressive world you can't
call down syndrome disability but i
think calling it a mutation sounds way
worse
and then in particular you specify
genome but the bill specifically says
alterations which is intentional
yeah changes but also it indicates
alterations like i guess it was the way
she wrote it that alterations that
aren't bad like if you scroll up to the
top again where it says the word
alterations wherever that was see i i
don't i don't i i'm not a fan of this
article could just be the way it was
written because i i don't think it's
relevant but it's to to include context
because what if i wrote the article and
i put in china they've been you know
working with you know is that the bill
this uh it appears to be it kind of
seems to indicate that if they're
genetic superhumans you also can't
discriminate against them we'd need to
read the bill well superhumans don't
have to worry about discrimination all
right so we think yeah well let me tell
you something they will overcome the
issues oh you're right the more you do
for them the more they'll hate you
they live among us
god's energy is flowing through us
empowering us
it is it is the future
let's see well i'm trying to find uh
other sources on this one too yeah is it
is it report do you know if it's
reported anywhere else i'm sure uh i'd
have to i have to dig into it yeah i'm
really curious about this i want to do
but maybe we need a hard fact check on
that one do it are you gonna get the
neural net and go into the metaverse
you know um
[Music]
maybe but i'm not so sure that i want to
do it with meta as a company
you know i'd like it to be free software
so you can watch the algorithm yeah and
also i just i just yeah it's just uh i'm
not too keen on on facebook's and
metta's recent turn you know
can you imagine no i mean it's a good
point look at the way facebook
influences people with their algorithms
now and they say you know what i really
want to plug my brain into yeah i trust
those people
zuckerberg was on uh lex friedman's
podcast and was like i'm a so i studied
psychology i'm a psychologist so he's
doing like a psychology experiment right
now well it's technically kind of
unethical you know they got in trouble
for doing experiments on people without
their knowledge like things these they
chose to do things that they knew would
depress people and it worked i would
like to extra the uh i think that's the
way to say that uh the concept of the
metaverse from meta i don't think they
have they're just a a piece of sand in
the heap that's going to be the
metaverse yeah they'll have their own
highway
they still
version of highways unfortunately
they've taken the name i know it was
really gross yeah that that's almost
attempting to kind of like you know like
we say uh
vacuum when we mean when we say hoover
when we mean a or kleenex when you mean
tissue xerox yeah so that's what they're
trying and that's what they're trying to
do yeah you know they're trying to
basically monopolize the brand the brand
i'm not convinced this story is real to
be completely honest
it's on your website oh i know
and i absolutely have the standards to
see it yeah and then come in and be like
that's not something's not right here
right here well someone should read the
bill when they have time but i don't
even know if this is a real if this is a
real document
so hang on your website may be
publishing fake news absolutely good to
know
yeah so um i i have i have very serious
to be fair to the journalists involved
without because we we would want to be
sensitive the fact that we've just you
you just may have outed one of your own
people right i have a correction to make
too um when we were talking about the
bill
it said 70 of liberals think we should
protect uh ukraine's borders is more
it's more important than ours
cassandra was 100 correct i confused
liberal and democrat among democrats it
was 57 among liberals it was 70.
and so i got to be very careful about
but but i'll put it this way because
when when when we pull up a story and
i'm like wait a minute this seems to be
off the numbers seem to be wrong i got
no problem being like if you work for
timcast.com and i see something i don't
think it's right i'm i don't care if
you're timcats.com or otherwise i'm
gonna make sure because i i think the
people who read the site have a uh
an expectation of standards here that's
why people work for you anyway because
they like that
well so i'm trying to real time fact
check this because i have a high degree
of trust for the people that that work
for us but we make mistakes yeah and
sometimes something slips maybe tomorrow
you'll be able to come back on this
thing it may be it may be illegitimate
the issue is right now in real time i
don't know if i could fact check this
other than the sources that are writing
about it are seen seem desperate to link
this to vaccination which is ridiculous
right and it's kind of annoying yeah
because if there was a bill talking
about this the the immediate assumption
is it has to do with it even even in
this document it says physical or mental
conditions you know uh
on the job or whatever it sounds like
they're talking about genetic diseases
so the headline is misleading then if
that's the case right but it could be
your environment could cause the genetic
disease like burn pits we were talking
about last night people coming back with
like just traumatic injury and cancers
and things like that what he's saying is
that the use of the word alterations
would indicate would seem to suggest a
deliberate alteration to the gene which
is not disabilities oh otherwise it
would be a mutation yeah uh and i think
yeah it could be me or you just use the
word disabilities right if you were
talking i wonder if that word's getting
retconned is it becoming not pc to say
dis disabled or disability for a while
they were trying to say differently
abled yeah that's an older one but there
are pc equivalents to what we used to
describe as disability and it's not the
pc equivalent isn't geno exactly it's
interesting that they're going at the
genes they're focusing on the genetics
of it i do think it has to do with
crispr it's been around for 20 years or
something but his point is that he may
not even he's saying it may not even be
a real story i don't believe it but
that's where you need to look into it
but yeah you know i feel a bit bad for
the for the writer because they're not
here to defend themselves that's true
well so uh typically what we do is we
always want to have original sources
there's no original source including the
article which is why i'm immediately
saying the bill could be fake it's not
up to our standards 100 with no original
sourcing there's a translated pdf from
from a website that uh is questionable
at best translated from spanish to
english right so this is not an original
document it's not an original source
it's on a website that's questionable it
sounds like a journalism lesson it's
great absolutely
and it's also a standard lesson it's a
lesson in standards i have like
i apologize to cassandra because she was
like you said that i got something wrong
then ian said we need a fact checker and
i was right and you were wrong and i
wasn't there and i'm like i love you
cassandra cassandra is that the same
right oh it's a different writer no no
no no no cassandra fairbanks right so
we're picking up some mcdonald's oh yes
cassandra mcdonald well congratulations
to be fair pencils heavy racers you know
if if uh if
when news outs uh publish incorrect
things i just say correct it yeah and if
they're willing to correct it i say well
we move on what we're going to do about
it when they refuse to correct it now
that's the issue like the new york times
and project veritas yeah so they they
want to smear they want to lie and cheat
and steal and even admit it but then not
correct cnn cnn
if you get called out for this all you
have to say is the science changed
that's right that's right exactly the
science changes
these are these even better you can say
i am the scientist yeah
i am i am the journalist i'll just be
like i am the science i am the truth i
am the science no i am the truth i am a
scientific method yeah i get to write
like a speech like a short paragraph of
i am the science i am the method
i am the actor and the acted i looked up
radical antonyms because i'm like how
can we how can we be de-radicalized
without having to say be
counter-dependent on the word radical um
i can't it can't get me conservative
it's interesting you did that because
since being um let's put it politely
since having my show ended
yes right indeed there's a legal dispute
so i have to put it politely since
having my show ended on the uk's largest
commercial broadcaster i am starting a
new show on odyssey and it's called
radical because i believe that that word
actually when i was younger it's a
skateboard tim you remember this man
rad was a positive it still is right i
love that one so actually all it means
is thinking out of the box so radical
with imagine noise will be available on
odyssey in about a month or something
cool i guess radicals it's cyclical
though well because radical was frowned
upon and then it became a good thing and
now it's frowned upon again it's just
changes and why is that because why is
that because they were trying to change
the established order at that time so
being radical was good and now that
their order is in place being radical is
bad because it's a threat to what
they've built and i kind of feel like
you know like a bit like the n word if i
if it's muslims who have been
labeled with this word radical
interesting so i kind of feel like i'm
going to reclaim that word i love it you
know and my autobiography is called
radical as well so i kind of feel like
ownership over that word you could say
george washington was a radical that all
the founding fathers were well i think
they're radical thinking out of the box
is a good thing and you know to be
honest even if you're wrong and you're
thinking out of the box i still respect
you more than somebody's just following
the damn crowd i would argue that thing
outside the box is neutral if you do it
for evil it can be very bad
yeah yeah yeah i mean look that's a
moral judgment on the actual ability to
think out of the box but the
prerequisite to being able to change
anything is it's a necessity right oh
yeah you've got to be your own
perspective from the outside precisely
you know precisely now you could you
could end up having that ability like
any ability and do wrong with it and do
bad with it right yeah just like saying
have a you have a high iq and you can
use your high iq to do evil so you think
allowing yourself to speak radically and
witnessing yourself doing it via video
it helps you put a check on yourself to
not become too radical well look
everybody evolves right so here's the
other thing so i wouldn't be the person
i am today if as the
16 year old me i didn't adopt ideas that
i now very many disagree with right but
that's part of my evolution and i think
everybody every teenager
it's a rite of passage man you have to
have to you know every teenager goes
through that kind of
phase where they rebel against
everything and to an extent where it's
harmless where i say harmless has been
over where it doesn't do too much damage
we've got to be able to uh manage that
process because what you don't want to
do is discourage i mean this is what
surely this is what pink floyd's brick
in the wall is about right you know
teachers leave those kids i don't need
no education right yeah you don't want
to what you don't want to do is
encourage robots so we've got to work
out a way where innovative thinking even
where it's wrong is accepted by us
there's a right passage for young people
well
then you know wherever they end up are
you raising kids do you have children
i've got yeah i've got a five-year-old
and a 21 year old are you homeschooling
no are you considering it at all yes but
at the moment i'm not doing it yeah i'm
thinking about doing that too i don't
have kids yet but that's my plan yeah i
just don't trust this this robot forming
public school system yeah i mean what i
don't understand is the same people that
listen to
still to this day
would listen to say
we don't need no education and yet and
yet everything they do
is the opposite of the music i went to a
liberal arts college and what they told
me is that racism and white supremacy
run amok in this country and it's just
strange to me it's like it's like all
the cultural icons you respect are the
uh even if you know
they are the exact opposite of what
you're doing and the the worst part is
when those same voices now thankfully
pink floyd isn't one of these examples
but when those same voices themselves
flip and start becoming
really weirdly established neil young
yeah exactly right that's what i was
referring to
i don't think it's quite as ironic as
we might believe at first glance they
were trying to establish a new social
order that social order is here and now
they're trying to protect it
so yesterday's radicals become today's
conservatives exactly
yeah i mean
yes i get that point but neil young i
mean free speech right
i mean well yeah well and then of course
that's the principle you're always going
to defend
uh not necessarily if you're if you're
operating within a system if you're
operating within a system that
privileges free speech or believes it's
a positive value and you want to change
that system you're going to use that
tool and then as soon as you come to
power you're going to say no don't like
that but you see that's what that
demonstrates to me that he wasn't really
committed to free speech
or at the very least because also we
want to be charitable to some extent and
say maybe he was at the time but he
isn't any more one thing
you find roger walters today still very
radical
right now you don't have to agree with
him but he's still very you know he's
still very kind of anti-establishment
trying his best to think out of the box
and i respect that even though you don't
agree you know i disagree i respect him
in my radicalism sometimes i found that
i sometimes it was better to stay in the
box but i'd still just do the radical
thing because i thought it's better to
be radical but it's better to just be
right it's better to fit the process
whatever if it stands for radicalism or
conservatism seek the truth i like what
i really like is chesterton's gate and
so
it's the principle that when you find a
gate you try to figure out why it's
there instead of just mindlessly tearing
it down and if it turns out it's there
for a bad reason or does it make sense
then you tear the gate down but you
don't go about saying we need to
completely destroy the social boundary
before you try to understand it which i
think is what a lot of people who are a
radical attempt to do today and have in
the past
i think it requires a great deal of
strength of character to hold on to your
anti-establishmentarianism
however however whatever you know
most people don't have that and you'll
see that when you look at the way people
do things like raise their kids and do
their work and they're looking for the
shortcut they're looking for the easy
way out and this is because having
strong moral character is hard it's very
challenging and it's something that you
must hold yourself accountable with and
it's something that people are afraid to
do now i think it's just they're just
looking for the quick out i don't know
that's kind of what i came up with it's
like the panacea of having enough money
and the food and they feel like if they
get radical they're going to lose access
to that the panacea and then they're
going to starve or the kids are going to
go hungry so they're like
forced to inside the box it's possible
that we have it too good and we're
afraid to lose it they think they're
forced well no so this is interesting
you were mentioning earlier that there
are some people who are really afraid of
losing their livelihood and so they
don't speak out on these issues and
sometimes it's understandable because
they have a family to feed and the cost
would be too high for them and then
there are other people who aren't
speaking out because they're afraid
i would venture to guess though and
maybe this is a little pessimistic on my
part but i really believe given the
state
of the people
in america at the very least if we were
able to completely eliminate the risk of
losing your job over your opinions
i think a lot of the same people still
would not state them publicly because
what they're most afraid of is social
ostracism
which leads to can lead to cultural
oscillations
you have to cultivate that you really do
it's very important and to the people in
chet i did not go to the bathroom
tim stopped talking to the band
yesterday we did this video thing during
the uh the live stream of the of the
biden's campaign speech where all our
videos were on the screen we should do
that when we show stories because it was
so fun to watch all our faces at once
everybody got to see their favorite
character and they're like so fun yeah
they weren't taking this person they're
making faces
yeah so um in in the downtime i was
conferring with our editor-in-chief who
uh agrees that story is probably bung
unconfirmed uh the story is unconfirmed
no i'll come out and say it
sounds bunk had typos in it like someone
just plastered it up and it slipped
through
well i'm still interested isn't that the
buck stops with the editor-in-chief
though there surely i'm trying to defend
the little journalist here just because
they're not here to defend themselves
i can only apologize and everyone else
can apologize and say i'm pretty sure
that story's not real wow
normally i'm reading all the news every
single day but that one went up right
before doing the show and i saw it and i
have faith in our news team yeah
while we were reading it i'm like wait a
minute something doesn't make sense here
and so i started looking at the sources
which are um
dubious
and then i reached out to the team is
somebody in trouble right now yes
but it is what it is man
you know look we try our best pencils
have erasers sometimes things slip
through and as you know mistakes happen
but you know we try our best yeah we're
not we're not perfect
i just looked up um
chile genetic engineering laws and one
of the links is human world human
cloning policies
rice university yeah i mean i i i
suppose a story that significant if your
website's the only one breaking it
that's a bit of a rush yeah i saw
another website called daily expo zeta
uk but it's dated tomorrow the third of
march is it on the daily maybe it's from
the future is this the daily expose is
that what it is is it on that website
yeah it is yeah yeah is that where the
source was one of them
is that a fake site no no no no they so
they don't tend to publish fake news
yeah yeah but the link to the so the
link to the vaccines is just infuriating
to me is that what's on the daily
like daily exposed
vaccination right and the problem i have
with that is i
one of there's very few things that make
me legitimately angry but one of it is
when news sites
falsely frame things by connecting them
to things that are are
tangentially well i mean you'd have to
have a reason to make that connection
for example right a legislator would
have said this is why we want to make
this law because which is not the case
as a journalist you'd have to have that
link if if we published the article at
timcast.com and it outright said
some people have questioned china's
super soldier program in china they're
doing this i'd be like why are you
including that has nothing to do with
the news
so if there's a bill being passed that
says we did acts and we will now enforce
x you're done nothing else it's um that
story's actually from the 25th it's the
expose there's accent on the last e so
it's x pronounced expose i i suppose the
issue is there's uh uh no original
sourcing in it and that takes serious
so it may be true my issue is the
framing and my issue is if you're going
to source a chilean law you need the
chilean document from the chilean
government for sure not some some on
other websites translation of a pdf that
they've not sourced
so i'm i'm not a fan but hey look i got
standards
not everybody is me and i don't write
every single story but i'll absolutely
call out i don't care who it is
and uh we'll do better
but you know i i my only real issue like
i was saying with a lot of uh
mainstream news websites
is not when they get things wrong and
they don't correct them that's that's
the main issue issue correction so the
policy we have at timecast.com is any
change
has to be dot logged and documented yes
so like if we if we if we change a
single word for for like
even
formatting reasons we'll put a note
right edit editor's note after it's been
published yes yeah oh there's actually
something called
neurorightsfoundation.org
slash chile neuro rights in chile which
uh the expose references immediately
a bill to amend the constitution protect
brain rights or neuro rights okay it's
not it's not connected and it doesn't
prove anything but this is very
interesting chilean neurorights are on
them yeah the story is not complete
there so i'm hearing that there may be
something here but we would have to go
and actually find the original sourcing
document so for now we're pulling the
article cool neuro writes
real time fact checking from your
websites dude they're talking about
metaverse thoughts do you own your
thoughts to someone else own your
thoughts and that's where we end up with
right does someone else own the shape of
the neurons of your brain can they
patent the shape that the neurons make
to produce the memory let's go super
chats if you haven't already smash the
like button subscribe to this channel
share with the show with your friends
and if you still have faith in us go to
timcast.com and become a member because
uh i would love
to fact check our own website in real
time for all of you to watch so you know
that we take it very very seriously and
if you agree with that your support
means the world to us but we are going
to have a members-only segment coming up
just uh after the show it'll be around
11 p.m and that should be a whole lot of
fun we're going to talk a lot about
spirituality and religion i believe
among other stories particularly the the
tweet that magic has that uh youtube
would probably boot us for if we showed
but we'll put up on the site
all right let's read some super chats
all right let's see
trip sucks says ian i ordered you a
couple 20-sided dice one of them has
only 20s on each side and the other has
only ones use them wisely
check the mail in a couple weeks so 10
chance to roll a 20 then it is better
than one ten five percent well you've
got a five percent chance to hit every
number on a 20-sided die so there's two
twenties then i have a ten percent
chance
every side it's a two-twenty
two twenties and then everything else
was a one no no ian you're rolling one
right now there's you gotta get those
dice 20-sided dies
one of them
has nothing but 20s oh okay one of them
has nothing but ones there we go you
rolled a one already i'm gonna have to
roll a die to find out which die i have
to roll
there you go if it's greater than 10 you
can roll it you get a 20.
all right wired knight says i really see
world war iii is right around the corner
putin isn't going to stop he is
this era oh man
he's saying this this era is hitler down
with putin keep up the protest in russia
and hopefully they'll take him in
custody i think they're being a bit
sarcastic
yeah well he's not going to stop but it
won't trigger world war three
i mean do you really think so well
because i don't think i don't think
biden
and i don't think boris johnson are
going to retaliate in that way that's
he's already been asked to impose a
no-fly zone they haven't done so and
they won't do so
man when we had a guest on the show who
said
russia will not invade and they will not
go past car they will not go anywhere
near kharkiv they're not going to go to
kiev no i'm so we're not so we've
already been asked to impose a no-fly
zone and we've said no
well
my point is
they could they could just do it do what
i know fly zone who the nato the uk
so why would they though well why did
russia invade kiev
but we know that we know why russia did
it well no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no see we've had that discussion but
what oh wait no no no no hold on a week
ago there there was only speculation
from u.s intelligence agencies that
russia would do this and as far as we
knew russia putin said no we're just
recognizing donbass as independent and
then i said i i said i don't think
they're going to invade it that's that's
a that's absurd i don't know what they'd
accomplished you said that i went to
rogan and said they would and then he
did and he did a couple of days after so
maybe you're right on this one and i i
don't think we're going to impose a
no-fly zone
and i want to i want to make this point
too i don't i don't believe mutual issue
destruction is a real thing
okay so so if there's a mutual nuclear
war
who stops what do you what do you mean
by who starts so mutually sure
destruction the whole point of it is
that you don't stop right you end up
destroying each other right so if i drop
a new coin yoon you drop a nuke on me
and i drop a new back on you how does
that stop why would why would
you nuke me so that's different to
saying you don't think it's no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
i'm struggling to use a socratic method
why would you no i wouldn't no no i'm
saying i wouldn't choose no one would
and putin wouldn't but mutually sure
destruction is a doctrine that assumes
somebody has in the first place and the
only relevance of the doctor why would
you say that they wouldn't because it
would lead to mutually short destruction
no no no no no no no but it's not
correct why would someone
nuke and why would one country know why
would putin nuke another country so in
theory why you do it is because you're
going to lose a war you don't have
aerial superiority and the only trump
card you have is a nuclear weapon and
where you are
and you're about to lose right now so
where where do you fire the nuclear
weapon
what's your what's your target the
country that's conquering you but what's
the target in the country
say the capital city why why why the
civilian capital is that where they have
the weapons
but that's where they're so wherever
their leadership and command and control
is where you think it's based i mean
that was maybe true 70 years ago yep but
we know for a fact now that certainly
the united states government is
decentralized to a point that
dc is not relevant
to the the
operation of the united states
government
so there's there's absolutely zero point
in nuking civilians
dc
right say for example your
iran
and your israel and imagine iran
develops its nuclear capability to a
point where it has a weapon right
israel is in that larger country
iran is basically do or die they're
about to lose the war
and they say listen
either we lose and we all get killed or
we launch this bomb because i'd rather
we end the war in this way right how
would it end the war by killing
civilians
it doesn't it doesn't inhibit the
military
but see mutually sure disrupt what i'm
trying to say is mutually sure
destruction is a doctrine that only
applies once you've launched a nuclear
weapon what you're asking is why would
you launch one in the first place i
don't think you would no no no no no no
what my point is if a nuke was headed in
your direction
and eyes and your military military
advisor came to you and said we can't
stop it
10 million civilians will die you have
the option to kill 10 million civilians
of your own though it's not going to
stop anything but certainly you can kill
a bunch of innocent people
i i don't believe that makes sense now
when it comes to ideology like iran well
they want to wipe you know wipe out
israel that's a different question
israel may say we'll hit i i don't
believe israel would just be like well
then murder all of the iranian people i
don't believe that's true i believe that
iran might might say can we intercept do
we have to teach you know sti defenses
or things like that and try and stop
nuclear weapons and they may respond by
targeting key military infrastructure
but the idea that one country fires
nukes targeting a civilian base which
doesn't stop the war in any capacity and
then the other country responds by
blowing up the other countries civilians
which doesn't stop the war any capacity
makes no sense at all you're applying
reason and rational thought processes to
somebody that decides to launch a
nuclear weapon yep
and so
an ideologically driven nation may not
decide to launch a nuclear weapon
for the reasons that you deem right and
only if they're targeting another
ideological nation do you get mutually
assured destruction in the event of
russia say so it could happen
it could happen in limited capacities
between small smaller nations so north
korea and say
uh north korea and not i don't believe
north korea is okay so a sufficiently
ideological nation iran and
so when you have when you have like a
desire to wipe out israel for
long-standing deep-seated issues
but i don't see israel as the kind of
nation that would respond by saying
let's let's let's just eradicate the
iranian people
you don't see israel as a condemnation
that would say do you think the people
of israel retaliation demands this do
well i'll put this way because i
disagree with you there do you think the
people of israel want to mass genocide
the iranians no but but do you think the
people of
at least a large portion of iran wants
to wipe out and that's my point that if
iran were to launch it i do see israel
saying they've now taken out a city we
demand revenge
revenge isn't the same as wanting to
wipe out a nation is there revenge is
the revenge on the civilians
it's that country struck us we need to
strike back but i think that's uh
that may have made sense seven years ago
i don't see that making sense today
government i'm not so sure they would be
looking to make sense so uh you also
think about it from from the individual
yeah when it comes to the west i don't
see
an individual uh on average at least
certainly there are some people who
wouldn't care but if again someone came
to if you went to the average person and
said there's a bomb that's going to kill
you know 10 million people you can't
stop it these 10 million people will die
in two hours
you can respond by killing 10 million
people press the button yeah it's it's
like um
i i i just don't i don't see a
human emotional response not a logical
one i don't see a human emotional
response being like better kill a bunch
of civilians it's more like what i could
also see somebody
in a situation where nukes are heading
towards their country saying well these
people are clearly comfortable launching
nukes and if we don't launch something
back they could kill a bunch of other
innocent people when they have gotten
the message from us that you can just
nuke someone without retaliation keep in
mind the only time that nukes have been
used it was used twice right two cities
so you drop one on hiroshima it doesn't
end the war you then drop one in
nagasaki so say iran launches one takes
out one city there's a rational thought
process which i even question would be
the thought process but let's follow
that logic there's a rational thought
process that could say hey they might
target another city unless we retaliate
as a deterrent
that's assuming they're thinking
rationing i don't even think at that
point people would yeah the thing about
nuclear destruction is that they've
already the country's not going to
launch one they launch 80 at all the
cities at once it's destr
the assurance of destruction is that you
have already decided we are going to be
destroyed in 20 minutes completely now
what are we going to do with that
civilians outside well i don't know like
james made a good point
for the doctrine here why does that is
the doctrine but it makes sense it makes
no sense that's the point of it that's
why nobody would launch a nuclear war
that's that's not i believe that makes
literally no sense russia invaded
ukraine and the west you say is going to
do nothing they won't there is no
mutual drive towards
ukraine is getting flattened in many
areas by russia and the us should or are
these countries should be like how dare
russia we have every reason because we
were trying to win over ukraine but they
won't do it because of mutual issue
destruction
and and because they're all conquering
countries themselves do they take libya
able to launch an attack and no one
responds if they launch a nuke no one
will respond that's my point no but they
won't launch a nuke russia did invade no
one invaded back that's because we've
been because russia knows we fear
mutually sure destruction yeah and they
don't i think that the world's carving
up the world right now the superpowers
are taking we took we took libya we took
it i mean that's like an american colony
right now or like a puppet state or
something i think you're arguing what
that is the doctrine of mutually sure
destruction that someone could launch a
nuke and no one will do anything about
it no that nobody will for that reason
nobody will because it makes no sense my
point is and nobody has in in any facet
of war that involves civilian death
right now russia has engaged in a
campaign which has resulted in civilian
death and no one is doing anything about
it
so if so vladimir putin knows if he were
to launch strategic tactical or nuclear
artillery no one will respond if the
idea was that launching a nuclear weapon
assured your own destruction the us and
nato would go and flatten russians for
russia's forces at least in ukraine
that's the bit i'm not getting why so
russia doesn't need to launch tactical
nuclear weapons to do what they're doing
in ukraine they're already doing it
right so i would only go to that next
level is if there was an escalation why
does mutually shared destruction only
apply to one type of warfare to nuclear
warfare oh yeah it could be a digital
war the nature of the weapon but what
about cyber war infrastructure
destruction of water pipelines the u.s
could use surreptitious methods to wipe
out russia they're not doing anything
that we know of yeah there's there's low
scale stuff like the trains slow down or
something funding
so i'm not i'm not sure a uh say for
example let's say we you hack the uh the
water supply i'm not sure it leads to
that same the nature of immediate
absolute and total destruction of a city
is what we're talking of that would lead
to that retaliation i still think
there's that doctrine
applies
and uh i can see why it would be a
deterrent because of that doctrine
and it's held for so long why nobody has
launched a nuclear war against anybody
else because it would lead to that kind
of situation
where nobody wins and everyone loses i
think
the idea the idea of mutual issue
destruction is born out of
a lack of understanding of human human
behavior in nature
and i think certainly you know the chat
is lighting up saying i'm wrong yeah i
think you are but they don't know
because you're assuming human behavior
is rational no i'm absolutely not i'm
absolutely not you're asking why it
would make sense not like why you're
destroying my city would mean i'd have
to destroy it my question is there's no
reason at that point why is it that
vladimir putin can launch an invasion no
one responds to
that's the point right yeah
nuclear invasion no no hold on hold on
why is it so so this idea that i've not
been given a sufficient response as to
why only nuclear weapons are the special
category of we kill each other
because it's total destruction
it's it it's not though that's the
problem
bombing a city does not end the war it
may have 70 years ago but today when we
had january 6 these protesters thought
by occupying a building they would have
some impact on government and that makes
literally no sense in a digital age
we know that we throw through directive
51 through uh
what used to be the norad strategic
defense in denver we had underground
military bunkers i think you would be
absolutely naive not to to to believe we
don't have
your country right and i decide for
whatever reason i've had enough and i
launch nuclear weapons i'm not going to
launch one
i'm going to launch whatever 80 to all
of your cities right they're now coming
what are you going to do you're the
country what do you do
i've now launched them already nothing
then i win
i've won if you don't do anything just
like vladimir putin has already done
nobody hasn't launched nuclear weapons
i'm not talking about nukes that's
what's bad about applies only to nuclear
war but that so it makes no sense
that's why that's why nobody will do it
vladimir putin is of the idea that mad
doesn't exist which is why he invaded
ukraine and is telling everybody
screw off i got nukes and they all say
we're scared of this so we'll do nothing
but if if this logic applies russia
would have been scared of a retaliation
they're not scared of which shows an
aggressor can attack and expect no
retaliation
it happens all the time so i'm not sure
you're so look
mad as a doctrine only i i know what it
is no but i'm not saying you don't know
what it is i'm saying i'm not sure
you're applying it in this context
correctly
putin isn't worried about retaliation
when he says i have nuclear weapons he's
saying
if you
if you declare a war against me then war
by definition is a total war which means
it will become a nuclear war that is mad
in effect that is mad
literally being played out right
that's the whole point that the reason
why nobody's doing anything is because
of the doctrine of it's it's a question
of
will soldiers indiscriminately kill
civilians
i'm of the opinion the answer is
mostly no not always
so when given the instruction to fire a
nuke on a civilian target explicitly a
civilian target i am of the opinion that
people like in vietnam the soldiers were
firing over the heads of the viet cong
resulting in them getting killed that
most humans are too terrified to
actually be the person to murder 10
million people now there are some people
that would but this is a big problem i
believe still persists within human
behavior when uh there was a bank robber
it's a famous story it's an ir it's it
may be apocryphal but there's a story
and try try factor me on this one a
bunch of guys go into a bank to rob it
and the security guard stands there and
does nothing they walk up to him they
point the gun and say give me a weapon
and he does he was later asked why
didn't you do anything to stop him he
says i
i didn't i didn't know i didn't know
what was going on i didn't know what to
do it's like well you're the armed guard
whose intention
they don't want to kill anybody
that people don't want to kill anybody
it takes a special kind of conditioning
to be
i just i this idea there's not a soldier
wizzy but the idea that any person like
a soldier i'm i'm imagining an american
soldier i don't believe in world of
comic but villains i don't believe that
russian soldiers are all like mustache
trolling villains like cobra command to
go to an 18 to 24 year old kid or maybe
someone a little bit older who's got the
keys to the nuclear you know command and
they're going to be like i want you to
execute 10 million civilians and for the
average human being be like you got it
boss killing 10 million people right now
i don't think most people would agree to
do it no but that's not that the people
that do it are the ones that are trained
to do it right but the one instance
we've had where we came close to it was
a story that we talked about the other
day with the nuclear submarine and the
guy on the ship there's two captains
saying we should one guy said no and he
stopped them from firing when they what
was it they thought they were being
attacked it was three officers i don't
know if they're all captains or whatever
but they thought they had gone and um
that their the us had uh destroyers in
the area and they were nuclear sub and
there was depth charges going off and
apparently there were practice step
charges they didn't know they thought
that a shooting award started and they
were like we got to fire nuclear uh
torpedoes and then the two the two
officers were like yeah and then the
third guy alexi i believe is his name
said no we need to wait for command for
moscow before we fire and then
eventually they surfaced and they
communicated with the destroyers and
found out there was no warranty
basically they say he prevented world
war three in that moment by refusing to
fight i think there's some people who
would do it but i think well people did
do it in history
do what drop a nuke the united states
did yeah and we did it because if we did
a ground invasion we would have lost
more people that was the argument i'm
not going into the justice i'm saying
people did it that's the point so some
people but they're trained to do it but
this is you know absolutely i agree yeah
i just think the the idea that we see in
movies where all the missiles are flying
at each other is just it's movie movie
beliefs that people just think is true
they they're basing their ideology off
of like war games with matthew broderick
or gi joe well well i mean that's
because it won't happen but that's the
whole point of the doctrine that it
won't happen so what you see depicted in
movies is what the doctrine says will
not happen mutually assured destruction
is a doctrine that essentially argues
that that scenario you've just depicted
that is a very unrealistic scenario will
not happen for that reason
so the issue is
i i see what you're saying the problem i
think especially people in the chat who
are saying one
the idea would be that
russia decides i'm going to blow up
amsterdam well why would he he would
target a military base or an airport
first the use of a tactical nuclear
device nuclear artillery gravity bombs
or otherwise would be on strategic
targets to help them win a conflict yeah
so he wouldn't do that right
the only time the doctrine kicks in is
because the only reason you could
conceive of using a nuclear weapon
is out of a necessity to defeat the
enemy when you have no other option left
otherwise it wouldn't make sense and the
whole point of the doctrine is that by
the time you get to that necessity you
realize that it's going to lead to
mutually assured destruction so the
point of that um resort uh in necessity
isn't really it doesn't make the
difference but the major so so i guess
to clarify the mutually sure destruction
would be of military and not civilian
targets
yeah total war is everything because if
the civilians are making the steel that
they used
i think we've come to a a a a uh
development on the idea which is
important it's the governments that lose
yeah the people would end up being
mostly fine i don't think so if you did
a full nuclear strike of the u.s people
all it would be mass migration towards
the farms in the middle of the country
people would be starving and going
towards the suburbs and it would be full
chaos the economy would be shredded to
zero no electricity no water yeah but
still you you'd have whatever uh
somebody living in say indonesia would
be fine right hopefully
as in well i mean there'd be a global
economic disaster but they wouldn't be
dead
for all i know the u.s would nuke the
entire planet in that moment i don't
know
i i i think you know so what you're
saying is
it's the governments that live the
mutually assured destruction is just uh
we have no choice but to do it if you do
to deter you from doing it in the first
place
and that's why i'd argue it hasn't
happened and won't happen it doesn't
make sense for it to happen and that's
what the doctrine states as well i think
we'll see the use of tactical nukes
uh people people need to understand the
the uh
when which conflict as in not in this
conflict right now at some point not
with russia
i think it's possible but i don't know
if it won't happen but i'm not i'm not
talking about uh uh
i'm not talking about what i love to
cite as you know mervs i'm not talking
about uh
you know
i think it's possible we see like
kiloton bombs so one of the active yeah
nuclear artillery et cetera dirty
weapons biological warfare that's where
we're at these days right one of the
reasons i don't think nukes are going to
happen is in particular because what
you've got is for a long time the u.s
military leadership has long recognized
russia's strategic national interests in
uh eastern ukraine on that eastern side
of that river that we were speaking
about earlier to the point where i
posted this video on my feed actually um
uh
colonel mcgregor from the u.s military
was on fox
and um
he he perfectly articulates as a us
colonel
perfectly articulates what putin's
desire is with eastern ukraine and then
acknowledges that they've been aware of
this for a long time but keep in mind of
course that if you're a serving us
military officer you don't get to set
what u.s policy is in for example
funding as of battalion or whatever
that's not the military that sets that
policy
but the military being aware of this it
kind of indicates to me and this has
been around for years this kind of idea
that you know we can't keep pushing nato
eastwards u.s military been making these
noises for for a long time i think to be
honest we're probably past
the peak and the worst
i'd say of russia's assault in ukraine
if we operate under the assumption that
mutualistic destruction is the is
correct that means russia is going to
win and they're going to keep advancing
in ukraine they will win in ukraine they
will take it they will uh putin will get
exactly what he wants and he'll stop
only when he decides he'll stop at the
river you think well i think they're
already past the river with uh but
that's where he'll odessa right but
that's where he'll for example where he
when he calls it what's the country and
he'll stop because it's not his
initiative is his own interest to go any
further did you see the map that belarus
had that showed an attack into moldova
transnistria
yeah i've been hearing about that yeah
belarus showed a map that depicted four
attack vectors that have happened yeah
several that haven't some have argued it
is that they haven't happened yet
uh i don't know that we have evidence to
suggest it's predictive or just
speculative but it does show accurately
four attacks from russia could be fake
because they didn't get the enemy to put
their troops in the wrong spot well
russia already occupies transnistria
with about a thousand soldiers
so if russia is planning on moving into
moldova into the disputed territory to
stage troops that means they're planning
a western assault on ukraine
if that's the case then maybe this won't
moldova or it could be fake because if
it gets nato to put troops in moldova
when they're not needed
he doesn't need western ukraine he needs
eastern ukraine what he wants in western
ukraine as mcgregor said in the
interview we can pull it up if you want
quite good actually what he wants in
western ukraine is a neutral ukraine as
it was pre-2014
that's all he wants
and and if you understand it if i'm so
this is where it really winds me up that
we've banned uh russia today and all
these like
russian propaganda channels they are
state-owned propaganda channels but if
i'm playing chess with you it helps me
to know your strategy if i want to win
now why would i if you're telling me
your strategy why would i silence your
voice if i'm playing against you right
so this is why it makes no sense to
silence russian media you want to
understand what they're saying if you're
competing against them but so far what
we know is that
comfortably we can say that putin wants
a neutral pre-2014 style neutral ukraine
now because he didn't get that
he'll probably be happy with a western
ukraine that's neutral and an eastern
ukraine that's under his fear of
influence i think i think that's where
he's gonna end we went a little long but
we'll read some super chats go for it
yeah uh is that where we were gonna be
oh you're gonna be reading the guy's
name it's vasily arkapov as the russian
officer so we have uh brian says tim is
just pissed because the chili story
didn't take uh did uh because the chili
store don't take it out on your guest
uh no i'm not pissed about that um
but then someone actually responded the
chili law is legit it seeks to prevent
discrimination against workers who made
the uh develop genetic pathologies but
are not yet disabled keep up the good
work love from santiago so that's
someone uh saying someone might get
disabled in the future from a current
genetic thing they want to make sure
they're protected so uh
ghost of recon says tim the purpose of
mutual user destruction is to ensure
that if a country were to launch a
nuclear strike the destruction would be
insured before the first nuke lands this
makes it completely unreasonable and
unpalatable to fire nukes in the first
place
uh my response to that is i think it's
interesting that people are saying i
don't understand human nature when
they're making assumptions about what
humans would do in a situation that's
never happened
my point is mutually assured destruction
is predictive is predicting human
behavior on a circumstance it's never
happened with no reason to believe and
no evidence suggests it would
my my belief is that humans are reversed
to killing but uh
you know as as much as they could be
and
it's strange to me that people are
adamant something that's never happened
would happen with no evidence to believe
it would you you've seen alien too
yeah do you remember the guy who's in
the aliens are trying to kill the guy
and he's like god he pulls out the
grenade blows everybody the only thing
i've ever seen julian nukes japan and it
worked and we won and i didn't have
nukes though but it's not just japan no
one else did anything yeah no no no
other country said whoa they just wiped
out hundreds of thousands of civilians
they said america wins to be fair mad
only applies in the context of both
countries having nukes i'm just saying
that um
that's never happened before and so we
have no evidence to suggest it would
just speculation and what has happened
before is we've used devastating uh
nuclear weapons with no retaliation at
all in any capacity the evidence we do
have as in terms of human nature is that
what we do know is that human behavior
isn't always rational and that revenge
is a powerful emotion and if you shot at
me i know that a human reaction is to
shoot back now whether that's not been
done with nukes before we don't need
that to conclude that if you arms races
happen right so if you escalate an arms
race i escalate back from emotion we
know that happens so there is some
evidence to indicate that it would
escalate and that's the evidence based
on existing human behavior
with what happens in retaliation and
revenge and sheamus brought up an
interesting point like can you let that
person win if there's like a
dictatorship that launched nukes at your
country you can't let them if you're
okay maybe you're just gonna let
yourself get wiped out but like are you
gonna let them control the planet now
it's just in that emotions
remarkably complicated i think i'm just
surprised people are so definitive on
yeah so we mattered them in the iranian
you're right though in the iranian
context the ideological motive is also
worth considering martyrdom as a concept
in cert there as well we have this from
dan pitt he says tim bro like i said
yesterday if nukes were launched at the
u.s a retaliatory strike would be
launched with no hesitation i was on
submarines trust me the birds would fly
the issue is
people seem to have a very uh american
perspective on how the response would be
i'm talking about uh if if russia
nuked any country on the planet do you
think if russia nuked you know sri lanka
there would be a retaliatory strike sri
lanka doesn't have nukes but say
pakistan right and india they they
destroy this this might so they would
destroy each other i can guarantee you
that pakistan but there's ideology there
yeah that's the point but then most
nuclear powers have ideology so i i
think the i don't believe the us
is mo i think it's governed more by i
think this country has lost ideology for
sure i think we're fractured and we're
driven more by conquest and power of
corporate elites and neolibs and neocons
but uh but i digress i think the issue
is people who have nukes don't have the
same ideologies they don't have the same
beliefs they don't have the same uh
intentions the u.s certainly might do
this a lot of people seem to have an
american perspective yes we will nuke
you don't you dare but what about other
countries would they do the same thing i
i don't believe there's a uniform
response to this and the only evidence
i've seen is that after the u.s dropped
nukes
certainly other countries would have
reason to declare war on the united
states for such an egregious action
certainly
i mean i suppose
bombing the two major uh cities in japan
they just said we give up
you know
yeah i mean look you've got to consider
why iran's chasing nukes at the moment i
think people nations consider it as a
leveler yeah and uh that's because
they're subscribing to mutually sure
destruction as a doctrine the reason
iran wants nukes is it knows it cannot
defeat israel in conventional military
terms and wants to therefore level up
with israel and the only way it can do
that is through nuclear weapons i wonder
if this is like an uh an islamic
allegory because i was trying to get
into islam and understand it and what it
looked like is muhammad was teaching
them like
peace at all cost unless you're backed
into a corner and you have no choice
then you fight like hell and so the u.s
invasion of iraq and of genesis put
these people in the corner and now
they're like well jihad or whatever you
want to call it but and so that's kind
of the mutually assured destruction
thing like if you're going to attack me
and put me in a corner
my faith dictates that i do this well i
mean that's why i mentioned martyrdom
if you've got a psychology in a nation
that would prefer death over defeat
you and
i would argue that's why nukes were
dropped on japan because they wouldn't
surrender because the
the mindset prior to the end of that war
in the japanese imperial mindset was
very much if you think terms of samurai
dignity honor warrior mindset was very
much that's why they would fall on their
sword which is where that idea comes
from that they would prefer um
taking their own lives then defeat on
the battlefield now in the muslim
version of that it's martyrdom over
defeat so where you prefer death to
defeat um that could be the japanese
version of falling in your own sword in
the islamic version of that
you wouldn't just kill yourself you'd
want to take out as many of the enemy
with you as possible before you die
because you believe there's something
after that so it's not irrational within
the internal logic of that mindset you
think you're taking out as many of your
enemy as possible and then you end up in
some eternal paradise so you're not
actually dying you're going to an
eternal life and you've also killed the
enemy in the process
yeah there's something glorious about a
hero that sacrifices him or herself for
to destroy the enemy but that's very the
important point i'm making here is it's
very real for the person that believes
that it's real it's more real
for the person that believes it than any
form of real is for somebody that
doesn't believe anything
like it's hard to explain that mindset
it's a hundred percent conviction yeah
that this is what's going to happen and
it's done willingly and with honor and
then is celebrated i would love to talk
about that in the after show maybe well
so so yeah we have like you know i think
we've
we might be getting a little circular on
the mad stuff and a lot of the super
chats are just making similar points and
kind of just joining the argument so i
don't want to just rehash all the same
stuff
but uh
other than that we have a bunch of
people pointing out that the chili story
is correct but it's poorly framed that
the the story in chile was about
non-discrimination for people with
genetic disorders like i'd assumed and
that we we needlessly included
information the original source was
daily expose
so uh let me see this is uh marco
antonio aravena says chilean here
alterations in this context means issue
or problem if we were talking about
modification we'll be talking about gene
therapy also is a work law against
discrimination so it appears to be true
but when you translate it it doesn't
translate properly without someone from
chile explaining to you there's no need
to connect you to vaccinations anymore
if that's the case and that's what the
daily expose had done yeah they had said
you know they'd linked them and we we
certainly should have done that but i've
been explicit with the with the crew
before don't combine stories because
it's like nebulous connections yeah well
so here's what we're going to do we
argued a bit too much and i don't want
to go uh uh
too late so we're going to go to
we're going to go to uh the members only
discussion so head over to timcast.com
and become a member if you want to
support our work if you appreciate the
fact-checking and real-time corrections
and scrutiny we have for even our own
work and you want to help support our
journalists as we continue to do better
and get it right please become a member
but also we're going to record that
member's only segment it'll be around 11
or so p.m so you don't want to miss it
it's going gonna be fun i really
appreciate your guys support everybody's
helping make it possible you can follow
the show at tim cast irl you can follow
me at tim cass magic do you want to
shout anything out your show your
socials just watch out on my odyssey
spelled odyswee watch out for my new
show that's gonna appear on there uh
give it a couple of weeks to a month uh
until we get ready meanwhile you can
find me on substance uh you can find me
on twitter and get her at magic knowers
right on
sheamus what's up homie i am seamus
coughlin
the love doctor coughlin those are my
credentials trust the science believe me
on these issues i run a youtube channel
called freedom tunes we do cartoons we
release a new one every single thursday
which means we're going to have one out
tomorrow about obama's i'm sorry bidens
what's wrong with me no i'm not biden
the gaffes are contagious
we're going to be releasing a cartoon
tomorrow on biden's state of the union i
think you guys will enjoy it i am ian
crossland i'm looking forward to seeing
you guys again you follow me ian
crossland.net and if you want to see our
multi-video camera thing at some point
in the future give me a solid 100 in the
chat
catch you later nice i was gonna say
that chile a lot actually does sound
like a real thing because i have like a
genetic disorder that somebody could
technically fire me for so i'm kind of
glad that it's a thing really curious
where it's coming from whether it's the
wef or something and probably not
vaccines but anyway i digress now you
guys can follow me on twitter and
minds.com at sourpatchlids we will see
all of you over at teamcast.com in that
special members only segment we are
going to discuss religion and
spirituality should be a lot of fun and
maybe we'll solve all the world's
problems thanks for hanging out we'll
see you all then
you